e
it's 10 o' we can get started
so my goal for to for today and and
possibly tomorrow is to finish house
build to as given to us by the governor
obviously there's going to be plenty of
additions and other things um or at
least get as close to that as we can in
particular Melissa do we have um the
Department of Justice coming at some
point to talk about their sections I
have an email out to them I gave them
the option for today or tomorrow but I
did message them this morning
so I do not have a response back so I
would assume that will be probably
tomorrow okay all right so so we may
have to skip over those particulars ones
um so
why don't we sort of just go you know
start at at page one and um talk about
you know go through the list of House
Bill two um so the first one is bail now
we know there's a big Bill coming uh to
the house Thursday so I was tending to
think we just take this out and put that
in or or or talk about it when we get
that bill does that make sense yeah yeah
I don't think that bill is all that
different from this one but the the
problem with the bill um as I understand
it that's being voted on on Thursday
with the committee amendment is that it
does balloon
costs um and and
mostly um costs for counties right
because basically that bill says it
lowers the um the the threshold for
keeping somebody in jail without bail so
they they they would stay in jail longer
and and the um criteria for keeping them
is lowered so
therefore probably a lot more people
would be in jail that's that's more you
know County costs so uh so there is a
cost element to that bill that we will
want to talk about okay any other
thoughts on bail anybody want say
anything we're happy okay so we're going
to wait on that one um all this um
fishing game move move things
around um between you know shuffle the
the the chairs between fishing game and
um uh dncr and and and Department of
Environmental
Services I'm generally okay with that I
mean I don't any any objections um well
I mean I think I'm generally okay with
their proposal um I think you know we're
going to have a public I mean I I'm not
sure you're proposing to vote on it
today but yeah I was I'm well because we
haven't even had a public hearing on
this and I think a lot of people are be
really interested in this and um I I
just feel like you want to wait till
Friday I would yes Mr chair I think that
would considering it's a huge uh
portion it's Wednesday we're having a
regular house bill yeah Wednesday
afternoon I mean I I will I'll I'll
mention one thing that I had a thought
about um and that is that all the with
all the uh I'll call it rig rolling
around I believe this section is
supposed to be effective upon signature
by the governor and um it just seems to
me that pushing it out to December 31st
or something like that would make sense
because I don't know how they can have
everything like up and running by the
day that she signs it so that was my
thought yeah my my general impression is
all these people are working together
anyways right it's it's just one happens
to be sitting here but when they move
they're still going to be doing their
same job so well we can ask Dees too
about that I mean sometimes those sorts
of things don't make it in here because
people are watching the substance and I
also I was just going to say I think the
fishing game positions were funded
through December 31st I don't know but
we can we can talk about that's accurate
they funded with arpa funds through uh
December 31st and then they'll switch
over to General General funds in January
okay okay all right so uh Melissa do you
want to prepare an amendment maybe to to
to uh change that effective date for all
of these sections sure would you that we
can consider yep um and I believe our
the Amendment would also include
removing the
$275,000 appropriation for that
scientist position because that's in hb1
already so it's a double appropriation
on that one oh yes yeah that's a good
idea but that could be right away right
I figure I would do one big Amendment to
the section if that's what you wanted
and and and generally include the their
red line and that was going to be my
second question and include their Red
Line because I didn't so the main so
we're talking about sections two through
five I guess right yeah and I didn't see
anything else um specifically
objectionable the one thing the one
thing that I one concern I had with you
know what Dees was shared with us um and
it's in their red line that I think is
related to all of this is the fact that
they say they need 180 days to do the
rule making MH seemed really long
I mean they changed it from 30 to 180
days I mean I think I'm sorry go ahead
representative evil yeah um I just I I
agree with you it seems long but I think
that when um Mr kpo was here he said
that they didn't intend it to take that
long I think what they were trying to do
was give themselves a little space so
and I and I there's a middle ground I
heard that and I guess yeah that's what
I'm thinking is you know let's let let's
make it let's set I say so so let me
point out the actual sentence here is
such rule making shall begin within such
and such so it's not that it has to be
accomplished by by so it's even worse
exactly right I think what he said was
the whole jel car process so the the I
think the the problem is that they were
interpreting it when they were talking
like they had to have everything done
within the 180 days and Jael car is a
very there's a long process for adopting
rules I don't know Melissa yes they
spoke on two parts they said one
Gathering all the entities that would be
involved to make sure that the ru making
is what is expected from the public so
all the um uh stakeholders would need to
be included and then the second part I
do think they were concerned of just
hitting the to have the rules effective
but I do agree it does read a little bit
different in here that it said shall
begin it doesn't they shall be completed
yeah so yeah so maybe complete or I
don't know maybe um we begin within 90
days or something like begin within 30
and end within 90 or something or well
ending is tough CU ending is tough or
maybe well I would say begin at least
within 60 I think I think yeah well the
question is if we think of begin as when
they hold the public hearing for these
rules yeah they're not going to do it
within 30 days that that wouldn't happen
within 30 I mean I'm a fan of 90
honestly 90 okay all right let's
let's a completion date as well and say
maybe the completion is 180 because
that's not under their control really is
the problem so so yeah so let's let's
make the N 180 to 90 Melissa and um and
we'll just have the understanding that
begin means the public hearing for those
rules right because you know sometimes
they have a public hearing then they go
back and make changes and all kinds of
stuff okay um other comments on these
sections okay good all right so now we
can go on
to um that was section two through five
right so now we have this native plant
stuff uh six through eight I guess it is
well let's
see um starting
on page
eight
yeah no I don't I don't have a problem
with
this just a
definition right yeah is this a new fee
here
for charge a fee for um screen the
database no that's existing Lang Melissa
on so on page nine uh Roman one I think
that's just a deletion from the existing
statute isn't
it
P I'm looking at page eight oh I
apologize I was on line uh
30 I know that's a new fee yeah but I
think it's okay
just I think it's the it's the fee that
was being charged by dncr and now
they're allowing it to be
charged because they're switching
because they're moving them around I see
so this is more of moving people this
section it looks that way because the
reason I thought it was different was
the the red line thing was changes to
sections 2 through five but maybe maybe
they're just not changing this is more
of the same yeah okay yes so their their
notes say that um it's just to help move
the functions um of Performing the
environmental review to Dees okay so so
it's really two through eight that's
moving those people and yeah Mr chair um
represent thank you um so th because
right now I the uh revenue from those
fees is going to be in hb1 under New
Hampshire native uh uh the natural and
cultural resources correct so will this
amendment change hb1 so that that
revenue from fees is now with Dees and
not an
hgr is that what we yes I I would think
so right because it's going to
Department of Environmental Services so
is in hb1 are the the fee revenues which
department is that under now because
that hb1 would have to be amended to
reflect the revenue being received in
Dees so the fees don't necess
necessarily tie to the payment um and
what's in hb1 is those positions will be
moved in this section from
dncr to uh Dees and then it will be
funded with the other agency um the
other agency funding so on a high level
it doesn't work exactly the way you said
but yes those you'll have a a reduction
in other agency income in dncr and
you'll have an increase in other agency
income in Dees so they'll offset each
other in the budget so at the end it's a
zero okay so Net Zero um so but right
now if I were to go into hb1 I would see
those positions not in Dees so hb2 would
then change
hb1 for the positions not for the
revenues that's what I was making this
for the expenditures it would change the
expenditures from um dncr will have a
reduction and expenditures when we want
you guys to vote vote on the hb1
adjustments because there's a couple of
changes and we can talk about that next
week because what is in hb1 currently
does not reflect what dncr and Dees
asked I think the governor moved um
three positions and there should have
only been one position that moved so
there's some me moving parts for hb1
okay I got it thank you and the other
thing is line 32 on page eight makes it
clear that these fees are there to cover
this particular cost yeah right so
they're connected they do cover just in
hb1 you're not going to see those fees
in the line is what I was saying that's
fine okay so now we are through number
eight I guess it is right y so let's go
to number are you okay with their red
lines you want me to do the amendment do
you want that to be do you want me to
push out the effective dat and change it
to 90 days yes except for the double
counting part
yes six through
eight six through eight yes so six
through eight their red line just wants
to chain the rules on that section as
well from 30 to 180 would you like that
to be 0 that should be 90 and the
effective date bumped out on that one as
well um
yes it's all part of the thing okay are
we voting to approve or just I think
we're going to be informed we we decided
to listen to in case somebody comes to
the public hearing and gives gives us
new information we're going to wait till
Friday okay all right and what I'll do
if it's fine with you Mr chair based on
this we'll get the Amendments ready so
then when we go and vote on Friday
you'll have the Amendments language in
front of you okay good all right now
boat house so
um there are
two two sections I guess or more there's
a few sections here um
this is section oh wait a
minute section n nine okay yeah so it's
through um N9 and 10 and
11 well nine and 10 is the defition 15
and 16 yeah it's it's kind of two places
I guess it's pull it out 9 10 15 and 16
is a little hard to do on the okay
so right so this is about Boat House
let's talk about boat houses right so
right now um so I looked in one thing he
said to us was they're currently only
permitting boat houses dug in right
they're not permitting them
overwat but they lost a lawsuit related
to it and that's why they want to add
this stuff right okay so I searched the
rsas for the word Boat House it appears
exactly once okay and in the definition
of Boat House well it's it's it's part
of a definition of of a water related
structure or something like that right
so it's only in a definition and that
particular definition says that the
structure can be over water right so it
has it doesn't say anything about dug in
or or not dug in or whatever so it's
clear why they lost this lawsuit because
there's no
law making that distinction it must be
just their rules right so
um anyways and and there's nothing about
as far as I can tell there's nothing
about height in that section that
current law so putting this stuff in is
is definitely new law um maybe it's
reasonable because it's you know a big
new practice but it's anyways we should
be aware of it I guess
Mr chair yes M representative Griffin
this is stuff that clearly should be a
separate bill it's there's no reason for
it to be an hb2 it isn't really
supporting the budget it's changing the
law yeah you know I I would tend to
agree with you with the one exception
that it's urgent because because um they
lost this lawsuit their current
practices are changing Etc so
um I did ask for uh the resources
committee to give us feedback and um
haven't quite gotten it yet but um in
general the only thing I I spoke to the
chair of resources he had looked it over
he had his his vice chair had not yet
looked it over and they said uh they
didn't highlight this this section yet
so I don't know representative evil I
mean I I would I agree with both you and
representative Griffin but I I think the
more persuasive issue is that they
really feel that need that needs to be
done because of this lawsuit I mean the
only other thing we'll see what the
public hearing uh produces but I don't
know about you representative the other
I haven't heard from a Lakes Association
about this to express any concern um and
they're aware of HB to and the various
Provisions so okay I mean I'm I'm okay
with this I think it's I think it's
needed okay so represent C yes uh thank
you Mr chair I agree because it's an
urgent matter I am I am on uh one of the
uh uh Lake Conservation groups and this
would be a disaster if people started
building hotels you know so on the water
on the water since they they lost the
lawsuit and since there's currently no
guard rails around
what you can build this needs to go in
and it needs to go in immediately okay
all right so nine and 10 are just
definitions right so
um can we can we maybe approve nine and
10 is
that and I'll second it or all those in
favor yes against what give a chance to
catch okay all right um
so we'll get back to boat house or do we
want us as long as we're here on boat
houses where's the second part of it
it's uh fif page 12 uh section
15 okay yeah so this is the boat house
requirements so there's a number of
things in here that bothered me
um first of all the effective date
February 20th 2025 so this feels like
Expos
facto law
right so I tend to think that should be
July 1 no I agree yeah anyone
else
yeah I would agree except you've got to
assume that they worked this out with
the attorney general and based on the
lawsuit maybe they feel like this the
date they needed I'd be I'd have
some anxiety about changing that without
Melissa you asked the question right or
Jack I mean I would just say that it's a
very specific date yeah it is but but
can you p is it legal to pass law that
happens in the past I don't think so I
don't think so either I don't but all
right well Melissa ask the question okay
and the other question I would ask about
this is is the sentence describing this
thing minimize storage to accommodate
only life jackets paddles Etc I mean
this seems way too detailed right I mean
why are we you know what we care about
is this building size right the height
uh the one story Etc right but but
what's in the building I mean you
know represent c yeah the
unfortunately um people could start
parking cars in there and you know and
there off-road vehicles and stuff like
and then um so the intent is to only for
boating equipment or anything associated
with boating and being or or lake
activities like swimming fishing boating
uh so that's the intent so that's why
they throw a little bit of detail in
there so I wouldn't get too picky on it
I see I have another representative
Griffin I have another issue with u 6
and that's the U raising the fees
annually I I don't think it's a good
policy for us to turn the raising of the
fees over to to
bment yes and but I don't see that where
am I where are you looking well I'm
looking at hb2 no no but what line of
page 12 we're doing
this well we're on boat houses yeah
we're still on boat house yes well but
we I agree with you and we'll come back
to that okay yes repres one more comment
about the dates there could be some
people who already have contracts
ongoing with contractors for
construction of a boat house they would
have already paid the $400 whatever so
that I think that I I realize what
representative eel said that this may
have been uh legally required to put the
state in but i' I'd also want to have an
exception if we could for people who
have ongoing contracts signed before
February
21st because they may have already
expended a lot of money for a project to
find out that it's not going to be um
legally yeah constructed represent I
would say they're in a well I I don't
know
but seems like they're pursuing an
illegal action because of the because of
the um I don't know and just going along
with what represent of camell said if
you don't limit it in some way people
are going to build houses and put in
apartments and um I mean that's another
thing when those guys are talking to the
attorney general they might raise
existing
contracts yeah I think it's I think we
need an answer to
that page
12 yes um anyone else like to wa on all
right why don't we just ask the question
um number one why is why is that
particular date in there number two is
it actually legal
because and and
maybe what's in no it's not law yet
can't it's they can't go retroactively
after someone who's already started to
do something so yeah on the other hand
so representative rung is
somewhat um correct I think because
um
nobody if you're going to start
construction so this is about starting
constructed after right there's a whole
bunch of things that lead into
construction getting the permit and
making your plans and and going to the
planning board and all these kind of
things right and so um
so if we made it constructed after July
1st right then we're not necessarily
going to
interrupt the the things that are
happening now are kind of the planning
stage right and so you know there
probably won't be any such thing built
unless it's already
today you know they've started
construction right so I know
anyways let's ask the question Melissa
and we'll find out okay all right so
that's enough about boat houses um let's
go back
to where were
we page n page
10 fees oh the fees penalty the penalty
that one's okay I think because because
basically we're adding a new thing you
can't do so this is saying the penalty
also applies to this new thing right
because there's already a penalty in law
in for something else you're not
supposed to be doing right so yeah that
that's just these two things go together
15 and
16 let's do the whole boat house as one
big unit I guess okay all right back to
page I think we're page nine at the
bottom section 11
yeah okay
okay right
so right so this
is uh so this is a big fee increase but
that's one of the things we're going to
be doing to um to balance the
budget and the governor did it ahead of
time in this
one so yeah I go ahead and represent
around
do have an issue with raising fees for
individual homeowners that are working
on a project for instance if you look at
a seasonal dock there's no disruption in
the in the the bottom of the Waterway
it's just setting something on top of it
or could even be a floating seasonal
Dock and um sometimes people do that on
their own and if we increase the fees by
50% I'm concerned that 's going to be
people that are going to be working off
permit and I don't want to have the the
the the increase in the fees discourage
people from going through that
permitting process and just doing
something on their own I see uh do we
know when these fees were set in this
particular
section I don't have the answer to that
I do know when we spoke about this last
time um representative wer said he's
kicking this section to Ways and Means
to get their input on it
okay okay and I certainly haven't heard
back from them he said he just said that
on Friday he had forgotten to send this
section over to them oh I see I mean I
wouldn't have a problem with the fee
increase if it applies to um contractors
or developers because those are
typically going to be larger projects
that um an individual homeowner wouldn't
be doing on their
own well and they're going to probably
make sure that they comply with all the
permitting requirements okay so so
there's two parts to the fee right one
is there's a flat rate but then there's
an additional so much per square foot
right um and so I guess what you're
saying is you want to have smaller
projects have a lower flat
rate correct or something like that um
all right well what we'll look into the
history of this and and um if you want
to prepare a possible Amendment we can
consider it okay um this is for fixed
docks only no
no no for permanent dos it's not for
like floating ones or temporary ones
that you can put in
or I don't know it's dredge Phil and do
well if you look at on page uh excuse me
Mr chair if you look at page 10 line two
it does include seasonal docks or area
M that could just be a floating do yeah
if but if you read the
uh the
application based on the amount of
dredge fill or dock
surface so you could have a dock surface
with no need to dredge and fill in fact
all I would argue that all seasonal
docks don't require dredge
enill they either float on the water or
they may just have some pilings that
that sit on top of the
sediment well go ahead I mean we can
talk to them again I guess I I uh I just
feel like they're trying to uh increase
fees to try to compensate for the work
that's being done in the department and
this is all part of that broader
discussion I mean I don't I don't know
if other people have heard from Lakes
associations or anything about this I I
have not and I you know maybe we maybe
they'll talk about it at the public
hearing but um I don't think they did
this lightly anyway yeah it may it may
also be excuse me Mr chair but yes go
ahead you know maybe if um projects that
are approved through a permit by
notification could be Exempted because
usually those are just replacement
projects
or you know they're more defined as not
having a imp an enir enal impact so I
think representative eil has a good
point here because these fees however
they're charged go into paying for the
expenses of the people doing the work
right and so those expenses have been ra
you know going up over time right so um
let's find out when these when the $400
was set and then we'll we'll go from
there
okay I'll I'll I'll try to look that up
okay just one more thing not to you know
but when I did bring this up with Dees
on
Friday um my recollection is is that
they did recognize that there are
different tiers to projects like there
could be smaller you know more homeowner
type Improvement or replacement projects
compared to the larger projects where
somebody might be putting in a
commercial dock or commercial structure
so um I I can pursue it with them Mr
chair but I'm where I'm thinking now is
having a two tiered fee system because I
think they did say just the I think it
was 30% of their permits are those
smaller projects homeowner driven
projects right but but presumably
somebody comes out and inspects it and
whatever I mean there's there's certain
amount of expense that is unrelated to
the size of project um not for permit by
notification though oh okay I'm speaking
from experience here okay you have a DOT
yes I I can give you my Saab story
sometime yeah all right we'll we'll wait
and if you want to propose a change
there we'll okay now the next one is the
one that representative Griffin objects
to and I do too um so this is something
I was originally okay with but I've been
thinking about and that is these
automatic increases
right so
um I tend to think um that it's
it's you know we have to change fees to
meet our budget today but just putting
in program spending over time I don't
like that idea I think the legislature
should look at things as they go um and
um so this is
there's no particular urgency I guess is
my point in in putting this in now I
mean it's it's
um we'll make this B we'll make this
bium work as far as these fees go but to
to sort of make it automatic in the
future I'm not that comfortable with
this represent does it I mean this
actually says right in there that the
fiscal committee would be required to
repo approve or deny
the increase I mean I think what and and
as you observed this is all throughout
hb2 and I think the governor and the
Commissioners felt like it would make
the whole fee situation less Herky jerky
if they put something like this in and
then had the fiscal committee review
it yeah I I guess I would like like I
said somebody who wants to help them out
could put this in as a bill right and
and it it's not going to affect this
bium in our budget and the whole
legislature could consider if they want
to do this kind of thing with fees or
not right I mean I I I guess I just
don't see um the urgency of us doing it
now I'm I'm assuming represent of
Griffin would
agree yeah representative run I mean I I
understand where you're coming from and
and in a way I agree with you but when I
look at some of the fees that are in
statute it can take decades for them to
be adjusted it's not as though someone
just going to oh this V is 20 years old
let me put in a bill to increase it so I
kind of like the fact that they have an
annual review um I actually think it
might be better to make it by anual to
be timed with the
budget um but I I don't think it's a bad
idea to have it in statute that fees do
have have a reoccurring review every two
years to be adjusted if necessary right
but but see my point is this is starting
July 1st 2027 right so you're perfectly
welcome to put in a bill that bill could
pass it could start July 1st
2027 right oh for all fees you're saying
for all fees this fee some other fees
whatever you want to do right you know
and then and then it'll go to whatever
the right committee is right like Edna
or resources or whatever and and it'll
be considered right just like you know
and people will talk about it and all
that stuff but to sort of hide it like
this in house not hide it but I mean put
it as you know one giant part of House
Bill 2 it's sort of unnecessary in my
opinion anyways representative camell
and then representative Griffin yeah
plus it says shall be increased doesn't
have any allowance for decreasing should
things happen I don't like the idea of
an automatic increase it's better that
we we we the legislature review these
things all the time and sometimes we
don't increase for 20 years sometimes
we'll have to increase every every year
but I think it should be reviewed by the
legislature and not be
automatic M representative
Griffin yeah in the interest of
transparency I would like to state that
I do not have a boat house
I do not have a lake house I have a
house in Mon and up in the hill there's
no water anywhere near me so I don't
claim to be an expert but I it would be
interesting for the sake of transparency
to know how many of the members here do
have lakefront
property if they want to volunteer it
okay I do not so I'm I'm up on a hill as
well I have a um a former river behind
my
house but there's no uh there's no dock
there's there's very little water in it
yeah represent um we have a a dock on um
Lake sunap that's part of a big uh dock
owning operation but I mean I'm sort of
uh arguing in against my interest in
this so it's not really
yeah okay I we have a right away tolu
Pond and we have a uh seasonal dock that
we that we have out on the pond so
okay um I I live a half mile from the
ocean there you
go okay depending on the storms I have
some you know o I have a little bit of
ocean front in my
backyard and I have a seasonal Cottage I
call it a cottage my husband calls it a
camp
but it's uh some in some rooms you can
actually see the outside from it so it's
but we do have waterfront on Lake
hanasaka where's that Leake um it's in
molteno it actually feeds
into Blackie Cove in um in Center Harbor
got yeah okay for whatever that's worth
yeah any other comments represent
Griff no you're okay all right
representative EV I'm trying there's
there's so many things to remember in
this process but I swear when Dees was
in here before on Friday we talked about
a banial review of fees and we took the
word
increases out it said that it was to
reflect the CPI and it was a biannual
review and I think representative Lehman
wanted to add in something there about
making sure there was fiscal committee
review
didn't remember go ahead yeah that was
what we talked about yeah and I think
Melissa was going to talk to to the
chair about the cost of living
adjustment being like Regional not us
but more I think about it I'm beginning
to agree with representative cells on
this there's no reason A legislature
couldn't just review the fees every year
um versus putting it in because the
chair is correct this will get buried
and people will forget all about it but
we're increasing the Fe well we're
increasing the fees substantially if we
agree with that this time and that's the
first step I don't think these fees have
been increased since if my memory stirs
me right like 2005 perhaps we
just Jack was just able to find it and
in 2019 is when these fees were
increased okay so that's not that long
right yeah so just for information
inflation since 2019 has been about
25% so
um so this is more we're doubling some
of the feed yes right well we're we're
50% percenting them I think is what
we're doing some of them are doubling
represented months um I I don't I think
if we included this provision and maybe
we changed it to BU anually I don't
think it gets lost in the shuffle
particularly if we have the requirement
that it has to be reviewed by fiscal
committee I mean what would happen every
two years is every every agency that has
a fee would have to update their fees
they'd present it to the fiscal
committee and the fiscal committee could
then make a decision mean like the idea
of I mean I I I like the idea of there
being a regular
review um that happens automatically as
opposed to hoping that some legislature
legislature thinks about oh let me
introduce a bill to address fees because
um otherwise we're going to you know
continually get into the jam that we're
in now where fees haven't been increased
for many years sure but but my point
is why should we make this decision
about automatic stuff among just us
rather than let the whole legislative
process work on that aspect of it right
so representative run um if you remember
Friday did recommend changing the word
increase to
change and adjustment so um but we would
not be setting president at all by
putting something in hb2 that should
have been a separate bill no of of
course not no and I'm sure we're going
to do it this time you know there's no
question about that but on this
particular item I'm I'm slightly
uncomfortable representative Kell yeah
thank you Mr chair um no we we're we're
not shouldn't be in the business of
raising fees automatically the reason
we're doing it this by this bium is
because we are in a serious deficit um
if we let this happen automatically fees
could be raised automatically every year
and it could be unnecessary we could
have surpluses in the coming years
hopefully we'll have surpluses so I
believe that this is something that
that's why we're here we're the finance
committee that's why we review these
things and if necessary we increase fees
but shouldn't be
automatic all right
so um should we should we take a vote on
removing section 12 you want to do it
that way I make a motion that we remove
section to section okay and I'll I'll
second that all right all those in
favor okay we got four opposed three
okay so we can remove section 12 okay um
at least I can cross it
out made some progress all right
13 all right where is
yeah Commission gr
extension this is trying to speed things
up I think is that what it is yeah and
just and and just removing the specific
uh Rivers Council provision okay and um
so we're okay with
13 okay all right um so representative
eil moves and represent cell seconds we
move section we keep section 13
favor yeah okay unanimous okay good
so um where are we here section 13
gotcha okay now section
14 so this is also an automatic increase
thing right so I'd want to take that
part out so we're going to need an
amendment for that um
representative Maguire yes give some a
little bit Melissa yeah backg so um the
requested Amendment for the section 14
is sen is a Senate Bill 110 as amended
by the Senate is what they requested so
their language I verified their
languages exactly um as what's been
amended by the senate for S SP 110
that's currently on its way to finance
maybe heard tomorrow but just for uh
some background that is what their
amendment is requesting in so there so
with the automatic increase is in the
automatic increase is not in the Senate
version oh I see but the other stuff is
the 150,000 Square ft and all this kind
of stuff okay correct y
so so maybe we'll end up replacing this
with Senate Bill 110 is that the that
was their that was de's um ask gotcha
okay well that's good because then we
don't have to think about it all right
um
y 110 as amended but it's here or it's
not quite it's in Senate it's referred
to Senate Finance oh I see it's a Senate
Bill gotcha so maybe we should take this
out all together or but but then there's
money changes yeah go ahead represent if
if in fact this is identical to sb10
except for the automatic language their
requested amendment is identical okay
the requested Amendment the red line the
red line do their requested Amendment
and take out the automatic part I that's
what you were saying in the red line yes
yes so we're talking about in the
redline document section
14 oh so this is a big deal right I see
okay
right
okay no but see the redline version does
have the automatic thing yeah that's
what I'm saying so we take that out and
then it would be the same I think as
amended is right that's correct okay all
right so should we be okay with
that yes yes okay all right so why don't
uh who wants to move this you
representative Griffin wants to speak I
have a question maybe maybe I missed it
last time we met um or Dees was here are
all these changes been run through the
governor saying it is the governor's
budget oh if you're asking about the red
line versus House Bill two clearly House
Bill two has yeah clearly House Bill two
has but they're making major changes to
House Bill two here and it's a
Governor's bill it would seemed to me
that it would start with her
and then come to us
but and and I failed to ask that
question last time although it was on my
mind yeah I mean I guess I tend to think
that this is a level of detail that
maybe the governor herself would not uh
no but I mean it's tracking here and
it's in her hb2 I mean the the Chang are
pretty yeah I understand but it looks
there's a little bit this stuff looks
slightly new right so the 50,000 square
feet thing looks
new we're okay with it okay and and if
and when we get cabill 110 we can
reconsider it if necessary okay or they
will or something like that so um
you okay with this yeah
okay all right so when don't we have
representative cells will move that we
accept the redline version of section 14
to replace the existing section 14 with
the exception of removing the paragraph
that the sentence that starts starting
July 1st
2027 so moved okay good and
representative eil that any qu more
questions what we're voting on all those
in
favor okay
opposed okay one opposed yes okay good
all right so we're now done with
okay
good um and now we're back to
boathouses so or we we decided to we
decided to wait on both houses okay
because that is the sort of thing that
people come to public hearings to talk
about I mean In fairness and we might I
mean we might have yeah okay um all
right so that's 15 and 16 now we're down
to um 19 and 20 so there's a bill about
this right so I can I just summarize go
ahead so I'm just going to say that um
there is a lot of interest in this
section um and there's a bill that has
passed HB
215 which I gave to you at the last um
on Friday there's a bill coming HB 171
that has moratorium language in it and
then there's another bill I believe
hb77 that's coming that they're working
on the amendment right now um and then
there's going to be the public hearing I
mean there's a lot of moving pieces to
this
so I think we can see what happens on
Thursday I don't think we've really had
a chance to talk at any length to the
ENA Folks at all because nobody was able
to come here um on Friday so I think um
I mean I really think we have to wait
and Mr chair you may recall I won't be
here on Friday so it would I would
greatly appreciate uh delaying I I on
Monday well or Tuesday I mean the the
thing is this has a lot of moving pieces
and and you know that this is a real Hot
Topic yes and and at what point will we
have all possible bills from the house
um I
don't uh I'm notel by the 20th yeah I
was just going to say think we get them
we'll have them for we'll have our set
this week and then the next week we'll
get the last set last
right
right okay but we'll Mr chair I mean
we'll know what the amendment is by the
calendar coming Thursday and and the the
one on uh the
moratorium I know is three three years
because they already decided it so I
know what that is I just don't know in
detail about
707 I just don't know gotcha but we'll
have it okay
um all right
so the other question that I have is to
what extent does this section affect the
budget I mean this looks like a lot of
changes to a committee and other I guess
there's a little bit of fee stuff in
here yeah there's fee stuff in here it
does affect the budget because part of
this uh landfill review is now going to
be transferred from Dees over to this
SEC and the SEC costs will be based on
fees so um I it will affect the budget
and I know it's something that um the
governor I've been told feels pretty
strongly about so to the extent it's
reflecting her desires
um and and the houses I think okay we'll
find out I guess yeah I mean I I really
think this is a good thing to move
forward with considering everything
that's going on there does there is some
urgency to this well all right and to
the extent we move forward we do it with
the house version and not with the
governor's version right well the thing
is that the that's what we're going to
have to talk about because the house
version does not establish an SEC but
I'm not sure they even really considered
it that's why it's really but so the but
the all en compassing approach is an
approach that is already adopted by the
house so my idea was to look at the
house version of the bill to look at
their comprehensive approach and just
try to see how make it financially and I
actually was planning on talking to the
assistant commissioner about it at some
point all right so why don't we task you
with coming up with a house bill two
Amendment okay in the this area all
right representative eel I just want to
let you know they um they being Dees is
also putting together sort of a
comparison and a side by thed for us so
I requested that because they I to tell
you the truth I did chat with them just
briefly afterwards and I said you know
we've got to reconcile these these
different things okay great they're on
it okay um but that won't be ready by
Monday right this is a big okay well as
soon as possible okay we'll we'll play
it like that
okay uh retirement system I okay
so now that we've heard from the
retirement
um
uh the retirement system about this
group two stu
um I'm I can't vote for what's in the
governor's budget because
basically um between the groups a b and
c that well not groups what are they
tiers
between the tiers ab and C do maybe I
should recap because maybe I understand
all this stuff now quite well but others
probably don't remember so um so the key
date in in the group two retirement
system is July 1st
2011 okay so they had a retirement plan
that um
allowed um that was fairly you know
moderately generous I guess at the time
and um and and allowed what is now
called spiking which meant that you
could work a lot of overtime toward the
end of your career and significantly
boost your
retirement um uh payments in such a way
that the retirement system hadn't
necessarily saved for that uh payments
because it all happened at the end so so
there were two major changes well maybe
more than two but there were some major
changes made on July 1st uh 2011 in the
budget because that was a year like this
one where we were very short of funds
and so a number of things happened one
was put more of the cost of the group
two retirement and really of all
retirement on the employees portion and
less on the employ EMP portion another
change that was made was to the
definition of compensation of of
um average compensation right so so
basically somebody's retirement the
payment they get is a is a multiply
multiple of three things one is uh their
average compensation over their final
some number of years right so so there's
a definition of that one is the number
of years they worked and one is just a
factor a multip multiplic multiplicative
factor and that multiplicative factor is
quite different for group ones and group
twos because group ones are expected to
have a 40-year career and group twos are
expected to have a 20-year career or
something like that right so 25e career
now so so the the the multiplier for
group two is much higher than the
multiplier for group
one um but they're but what they're
putting into the system what they're
saving over time is also much bigger um
to make it all make the numbers all work
out okay
so um but the big thing that changed one
of the big so one of the big things that
changed
was on that date was was the employees
were divided into these three
tiers tier a was the people who were who
were vested already in that date so on
that date they had already worked 10
years and essentially their retirement
system didn't change okay tier B was the
people who were working on that date but
had not yet vested so those are the
younger ones um now they're older right
but but but for those there was
significant changes to their retirement
system and we call those tier B and then
tier C is the ones who were not yet
hired on that date but you know that's
you know that's 14 years in the past so
now we have some right and I suppose you
know if you wanted to you could think of
a tier D which is people not yet hired
now all right um and so over the years
there have been complaints about what we
did at that time and we have enhanced
the retirement of tier B's
twice once was about four years ago and
once was last year and um but we have
not made any changes to tier C's at all
and tier C's and and d right and newer
people coming
in
um considerably affect what we're trying
to accomplish with these improvements
which is retention and
recruitment right tier B these are the
people who are now have been working at
least 14 years right so and they're
group twos so you know they're toward
the end of their careers right so and
some of them have been
working uh what is it if you know they
could have been working nine years at
the time so 9 and 14 so some of them
have been working 23 years right so
they're definitely getting toward
retirement okay what we are told by the
retirement system is that the stuff in
House Bill 2 strictly helps tier B and
does not help tier C and in my mind
there's two things wrong with that
number one is the ones who need help and
would would most help our goal of
retention and recruitment is tier c
number two is this stuff in House Bill 2
is a give back in a lot of ways on
spiking all right and that's one place I
am absolutely not willing to go okay so
because I think that what we changed on
July 1st 2011 with regard to
spiking was correct regardless of the
financial situation right it's just
something that that made the retirement
system allowing spiking means the
retirement system is somehow out of
whack you're not saving for the eventual
benefit as you go along right so it's
wrong it's you know it's it's that
simple so so I can't support what's in
House Bill 2 but what I could support is
what we had in house bill 14 1467 is
that it 16 16
1647 what whatever there was uh from
last year which was removed from
that um
uh by the Senate right so that Bill had
had had improvements similar
improvements for group tier B and tier C
okay but the Senate removed the tier C
portion and and left the TB portion so
what we could do is take this stuff out
and put back in the tier C stuff okay
assuming and and all this is assuming we
can afford it right because because all
of this is new money right you know it's
new spending and we're trying you know
we have hard enough time meeting the old
spending and now we and now this is an
ask for new spending
so anyways that's what I have to say
about this whole thing and I asked
Melissa to prepare an amendment to House
Bill 2 that would do just what I just
described which is change this stuff to
the tierc stuff right and so
I don't know if that what stage that's
in if that's ready or not ready it's
still pending in all us okay yes
representative Camrose thank you Mr
chair yeah I like that plan because uh
the fact is is that over the last four
years if you as you stated we've made a
good faith effort to make reparations
for the tier B people for what was done
to them back in 2011 but right now if we
have any money that we can't spend as
you said we don't even know if we have
the money money but if we do I believe
that is better spent uh going toward
tier C so that we can have retainment
and recruit and recruiting uh improve
our recruiting for these essential
services so okay represent Ms um thank
you um since this is such a big part of
hb2 and one of the major um points of
emphasis by the governor before we make
any changes I'm wondering if we
shouldn't invite the governor's office
to come in and talk to us and just you
know and give us a chance to talk to
them directly about you know what what
you know what they're doing why and why
they're doing it the way they're
proposing so Mr Jerry yeah is that yeah
represent a run yeah I don't disagree
with you Mr chair but one point you made
that I I I want to add some comment to
is regarding the tier B employees
because even though they may have been
working for 9 to 12 years we've invested
a lot lot of money and their training
and their experience and they're
probably in their 30s maybe late 30s and
what um at least from what I've read um
lately the changes in the whole labor
market and labor Dynamics is those are
the people that get cherry-picked by
other companies because they can usually
go into another company and hit the
ground running um I don't know how that
translates with government service but
um I just want us to just be wary we may
be be care careful what we ask for
because if we can't retain those tier B
employees we may find a brain drain that
happens um if they if they do happen to
leave I think retaining people in their
late 30s is as important as retaining
people in their 20s I understand but I
I'll respond to that which
is somebody it's it's it's harder for
somebody in that situation to leave the
job than it is for a younger one because
every year they continue to work is
another year on the multiplier for the
pension right and and we've already
increased uh the number that gets
multiplied by and I think we did it in a
way that's tiered so that the longer you
work the bigger the multiplier gets as
well
as the number of years going bigger so
there's kind of a double there's a
there's already in law I I believe a uh
an incentive to work long ER basically
okay represent run it it's it's an
interesting discussion to have because
if they do leave at that point in their
career they may be getting substantially
better income so do they consider that a
tradeoff with their retirement benefits
and many times I mean it it could be um
what you're saying just because many
companies don't offer pension program so
um so remember we're talking here about
group two these are policemen
Corrections Officers and firemen so so
we are not talking about companies
unless you know maybe there's some kind
of security company or something like
that right but generally
speaking point Thank you represent MTH
you know the other the other I guess
other concern I have is
um you know we're we're focusing on the
tier the tier B um individuals and as
you mentioned there are some individuals
in that group that had nine years of
service prior to this change um that was
made in um in in um uh in in
2011 um and they were hired with the
understanding that their pensions would
be based on the formula that was in
effect prior to 71 and that formula
allowed their average compens final
average compensation to to
include things like overtime Etc um if
the goal is to
restore um the benefits that they
lost then you know we we we should we
should we should also restore the
language around average compensation I
mean if we're if you know I think it's a
it's a question of equity and and and
fairness um and um you know kind of
restoring something that that was taken
away from them after they were
hired yeah and I think that kind of
argument was what was persuasive to the
legislature to do what we've done the
last four years right but but not the
specifics about changing the definition
of income um so I can I can yeah not
changing the definition we're restoring
the definition okay but but
there's strong reason to to to why that
change was made and it and it wasn't
just to save money at the time right it
it was
to make the retirement system save for
as you go along for for the eventual um
for the the eventual pension yes
representative well two things I
wondered if you had calculated the
fiscal effect of your proposal versus
what the governor has and then the
second question was how that aligned
with um the Edna recommendations or yeah
that were provided and to tell you the
truth I I just I don't remember spe
answer to the second question the the
and we could look but the answer to the
first question is we think it's roughly
half I think um is that right Melissa we
think this is a 28 million instead of a
28 two it's probably going to come in
somewhere between 25 and 27 million or a
one time a one time as opposed to what
two times yeah or 10 yeah two time in
this budget 10 year total I also want to
make one one clarification um for hb1
1647 that was passed by the house but
not passed by um the Senate and that is
there is a a gain for um tier B group
two
members because what passed the Senate
was 15 years they had to work at least
15 years to get the two and a half
multiplier the house version is 10 years
so group two tier B would pick up five
they would have to work so it does a
little fores I just want to point that
understand would beand but C's yeah and
and it probably I mean it's probably a
little more expensive because we're
talking about doing it a year later
right so the the longer you wait I would
probably you know I would think that we
may have to add like six half% to the C
to what was in the fiscal note last time
if you see what I mean
right I can see that point and I think
it may be offset by any people who have
left sure since then I don't know what
the numbers are but I mean this is a
detail but
basically the the unfunded liability
Grows by 6 and a half per cent per year
essentially right it's it's it's there's
an assumed rate of return in in in
giving them a dollar today if you don't
do it you have to give them a doar six
and a
half next year right and so uh because
we
didn't uh fund this benefit last year it
makes it times 1.06 5 this year kind of
but anybody in group b who would have
gotten their pension improved by this
and retired in the
meantime once you retire your pension
never Chang
right and so uh they would not count and
therefore there's some saving yes
represent mon I I you know I think
another thing just following up on what
representative eel said I mean um I
think before
we you know before we we start making
changes to language that's in hb2 I
think it's important that we understand
exactly what that language is going to
cost I mean when the people from the New
Hampshire retirement system were in they
indicated or implied that what's that
what's the language in
hb2 will not cost as much as it as the
money that's in hb1 you're right about
that by about I think it was like about
$10 million if I'm not mistaken but
don't hold me to that so I think it
would be important to kind of know again
I think it's important that we
understand from the governor's office
directly what it is that they were you
know what they you know their their
their perspective on things but then
understand what's that going to cost and
then if there's an alternative that you
or others want to suggest what's the
cost of that okay so we can we can
compare the two of them yeah Apples to
Apples kind of thing right okay
so so to what degree do we know the cost
of these sections Melissa do we I mean
did the retirement system give
us like a fiscal note type I'm in talks
with them right now so they have not yet
but they're listening now and they will
get that b but for H but for
hb2 we they they did the analysis on
27.5 million and that was overpaid over
10 years because it does reduce the
unfunded liability um I think it was by
like $100 million or something right
right so with that being said though
that's a 10year provision I don't know
how much of an impact it would be if you
funded it to the actual cost so there's
two options either 26 and 27 that 27.5
million would either go down or maybe
you'd pay it for eight years versus 10
years which in turn wouldn't impact the
budget okay maybe you can ask them not
as a tenear thing but as a all at once
type of thing right what's the actual
number and do that for both both sides
so yes represent month and I I think
what's important in in in in the in the
ask is that we ask them to to to C cost
it out you know without there being any
change in the unfunded liability because
apparently what what they what they
indicated was with the at the funding
levels that are in hb1 it would reduce
the unfunded liability by $100 million
well that's not what we're asking but
that's assuming whatever we put into the
they were assuming that we actually were
going to spend in the next four
bienniums the same that we're spending
now you see what I me I mean so that may
not be quite fair either
right yeah okay representative I'm sorry
Melissa yeah so one other thing to think
about so when you're working with the
retirement and funding you have two
costs that you have to pay for one are
restoring the benefits so I look at it
as like the backfill of the cost so when
you say the onetime P what would the
onetime payment be I assume that would
to be to backfill all the costs yes the
next payment would be your future cost
which is included when you have 10 years
of payments municipalities aren't going
to increase any um of their contribution
rates because we're paying those with a
general fund appropriation for 10 years
so if you do fund it at a one-year
backfill cost there will be a cost for
future years because those are a new
benefit ad and new benefit ads cost
money every single year yeah and it's
not possible well it's because we have
no idea how many police fire Corrections
people will be hired from now to the end
of time right it's not possible to sort
of cover all those costs
today right so so at least some of an
increased benefit
does go on the employers taxpayers later
right I mean it's just impossible okay
yes that's correct whenever you're
making a change to the retirement and
giving a new benefit
right even if it's restored and then
it's continued to be new that is always
an increased cost that will if not paid
for Forever by the state it will be paid
for by but we can pay for it for those
people who are now hired and we know
what they're going to be doing right so
we or we have a reasonable idea okay all
right so we're going to wait on on this
stuff but I I just wanted to be make it
clear where I'm I'm standing
on on these sections but but this is a
big deal um because it spends more money
anybody else want to make any comments
representative
Lehman and it was represent of Lehman's
bill which was House Bill 16 yes I want
to thank you for all your help because
you are a co-signer to that bill no I
would just agree with you Mr chairman I
think we need to focus on the tier C
that's what we're trying to do to bring
parody If you will to the retirement
system uh a lot of work went into that
bill by both Edna finance committee it
was the house position to do that as
well so I it's going to be at least half
the cost of the governor what I've
quickly figured on my napkin over here
so I think it's a way to go we we may
not be able to afford even that that's
right but I think at least takes care of
those people that have been left off
that we try to take care of last year so
okay very simple thank you so now we can
go to page two of our little
does everybody have this by the way this
is the uh the updated um so Melissa puts
this online by the way if you if you go
to the LBA website in the division one
section um you can always get this this
updated list so okay um but it it's
what's nice about it is the the sections
we've T been taken care of are grayed
out so we can know kind of where we
stand
okay
um
housing so uh this is page
43 and section 72 and
so um what we put in the budget two
years
ago um said that uh we we allocated $5
million for this housing program and and
um
so we said it shall not lapse until July
30th
2025 Okay so some of this money if not
all is unspent and so the governor wants
this program to continue for another
year okay personally I'd rather have the
money
so so um you know I would propose to
remove this section but I don't know
what others think about it yes um do we
know what the balance of that is in that
fund Melissa so I spoke with Bea earlier
this week I believe about 112,000 has
already been 112,000 is has already been
expended from the fund for a position
that was um created to handle this they
do anti anticipate that they will be
going to
GNC in June uh to obligate the bulk of
this
money and then I think the beginning of
July it will actually be um
expended but as of right now for any
grants there has been zero grants that
have been approved as they've been
getting the program up and running okay
so the point is if we took this out it
would be up to GNC to
decide whether to spend this or not okay
um all right represent month so it
sounds Melissa like if I heard you
correctly that um while the bulk of that
money hasn't been spent they have
identified potential
Grant Awards recipients Etc yes they
have exceeded the five million in
requests for Grant Awards okay so if we
took this money
away
then those people would be um anybody
who came in later than July 30th 2025
would be out of luck but but it would be
up to GN GNC could simply refuse this
item right that's also correct yeah so
um
anyways I just don't feel like extending
it let's put it that way
represent i' have a hard time voting
against the removal even though I feel
like a lot of this money is going to be
all seed up by you know by by the date I
mean just knowing how everyone feels
about um about housing I guess the other
thing I'd observe is this is I think
this is really the only financial nod to
housing that's in this budget because
she hasn't put any other money in it
so okay represent R and uh this 5
million it's not like we're going to be
spending five million more it's just
really it would be getting taking money
out of that fund to go to the general
fund if it is not spent by the end of
June so essentially what I've heard from
Alissa is that we there are
applications that would consume all if
not most of this grant already with the
money that's in there it's not a new
appropriation it's money that's already
there so I I would and I I also think I
mean but but bear in mind that the
general fund is $160 million short for
the current
Bia so personally if I were the governor
I would recommend to the council not to
approve these things right because
because it's her responsibility to make
every bium come out and and
not I mean what she did in the in the
budget
of uh taking 81 million from the rainy
day fund and from our point of view 160
million from the rainy day
fund you know that shouldn't happen
right so yes
represent yeah but I I I agree with
representative evil I mean if I would
if I was the governor I'd certainly want
to spend this because other than this
there's nothing in in your budget for
housing okay anybody else want to talk
about
this represent GFF is $5 million we got
to put that in perspective it's it's
hard to come by $5
million we're scratching to get our
share yeah of what we got to come up
with yeah and it's it's probably
the least painful piece we can take
away yeah representative c yeah and this
is housing is not a new issue it's been
going on for the last you know uh six
seven eight years and they fact is they
had the opportunity and they didn't
spend it and uh and now we're in a
position where we need this money for
other important things so I believe we
need to take this money all right so why
don't we try a vote and see what
happens all right um so I think it's
representative cell Mr Mr chairman just
just leaned over and asked Alyssa if she
could check but we had money for invest
New Hampshire to last time which was 10
or 20 million so she's going to double
check on what that amount is because
that was to go to housing as well right
yeah my my recollection was that we had
two one was for like 20 million and one
was for 15 million but there was money
that was appropriated for and this isn't
even different yeah this is different I
mean that's all correct yeah but Mr
chair thank you um but it's not 5
million anymore because they've already
expended some for the Personnel you're
right so if we took this action it would
be up to the LBA to figure out what's
likely to happen and put that in our
Surplus State okay and then and also
just to clarify this isn't 5 million a
new appropriation right it's money
that's already in the fund it's it's
money that was appropriated in the
current bium okay okay the current bium
is short the revenues have not come in
as as planned so so um this among many
other items could be something that
helps close that Gap okay representative
evil I mean the only thing I would say
is if there is a vote in favor of
repealing this provision the real effect
is that everybody just has got to get
their act together and get to G and C by
Jan June 30th of 2025 and then it'll be
up to the executive counsel yes I mean
so it's not like the money is going to
disappear it's just that it has to be
expended by the end of June yeah and and
in fact I mean the the executive Council
has the authority even if we left this
in to just say no to all these things
and you know so it's not
it's not an end of the world kind of
thing you know but but maybe we would
signal to the executive Council that we
think they might consider not approving
these things right I mean that's I guess
that's it
um yeah if you read this we're changing
the date that it's going to
lapse that's what we need to
remove right so that that right so if we
if we if we just let it
laps right
so exactly right if we remove section 72
and 73 then any money in this area would
lapse at the end of the B yes the
current B and that's what we needed to
do because Miss yes I would agree with
you all right so back to this Melissa I
just wanted to make two clarifying
points one um there was 10 million for
invest New Hampshire and then there was
this five million the house did have
more but they dialed it back
representative C Bry were talking about
the 15 million Senate dialed it dialed
that back so 10 million for invest New
Hampshire 5 million for this program I
also forgot to put one point that there
was also s sp45 that was incorporated in
hb2 on the Senate side that gave 250,000
for administrative costs so the 5
million would still be available for
grants that full amount that 250 would
have been reduced to
112 is it wasn't there also money given
to the New Hampshire Housing
[Music]
Authority I thought that was another one
anyway if your point is that there's
money that's there I'm that part is true
yeah I
mean just in general unspent money from
this current bium is like the easiest
possible cut right it doesn't lay off
somebody it doesn't you know so okay um
are we ready to vote yeah make a I'll
make a motion to um to remove the are we
just going to remove the DAT sections 72
and 73 yeah make a motion to remove
those sections okay who's seconding
representative Griffin seconds okay all
those in
favor okay what do we got four against
four to three okay okay motion carries
good all right now let's go to all right
so those are
done okay
now planning so this is um sections 74
to 77 and I wanted to ask the question
how much money is in these sections if
any are we allocating money are we
moving money what's going on there there
is no cost to these sections so so the
this is just allowing sort of a reorg um
for the division of planning and
Community Development they already had
someone in a position in another
division they're moving them over so the
salary isn't
changing
oh no additional position representative
EV I mean I just remember this
discussion and they just thought for
efficiencies within the agency they were
I don't know if they were moving a
office to a division or a division to a
department or it was just sort of
reorganizing things in a way that made
more sense and I didn't recall that it
had a financial hit to it it's just okay
they think it's a efficiency move okay
so I guess we can approve that does that
sound yeah I mean is it is it just it's
a non-financial I I believe it's
sections 7 uh 4 through
77 77 is is just a cleanup um it removes
a reference to a job training program
that no longer exists okay okay within
the agency I'll make the motion to
approve uh section 74 to
77 or is
767 7 it say
74 you tell me I'll make the motion 74
to 77 74 to
77 okay okay all right so it's been
moved by representative evil and second
by representative rung to to keep
sections 74 through
77 all those in favor yes okay unanimous
very good okay 74 through
77 we got that I mean that's not to say
we
don't make changes in house bill one to
to the planning department for example
yes okay feeling that was on right so
now we have
78 uh Workforce Development Innovation
fund that's the one I just spoke to
sorry I referen the wrong section that
one it just removes a reference to a job
training program that no longer exists
within the right it looked like some
renaming kind of stuff just
789 79 is the same thing
yeah I'll move that we approve 78 and 79
okay let let me let me read 79 just for
Grants here
um inserting because this is a new
section
right is
it um
yeah 79 is on page
46 so it's putting in this new
section oh that does does it have
money can I just change my motion to 78
and then we can talk about 79 all right
so representative evil moves and
represent rung seconds to keep section
78 okay all right all those in
favor okay unanimous good now section
79 yeah I read it and it looked
generally okay to me but I I'm going to
read it again here let's take a moment
okay so this seems to just give governor
and Council a little more input on these
grants yeah right because they're
already making the grants and they
already there's no new money to this I
don't think I don't think so either we
okay with that okay changing
ter terms of
office oh no just talking about section
78 okay yeah I mean I 79 I'm sorry s SE
I don't think there's money to this I'm
looking at the um our LBA friends
there's no money new money or anything
on
this no okay so all right I'll make the
motion to approve section 79 okay I'll
second the motion all right so
representative evil moves and
representative cell second to um keep
section
79 um all those in
favor okay good all right
now this is just membership
terms section uh 80 yeah but I was
thinking of getting rid of this
Commission on
Aging well can we just approve there I
mean why don't we just do this and then
you can then later maybe undo you can do
what you want okay well not exactly not
exactly I'll make a motion to approve
section 80 all
right all right representative eil moves
and represent rung
sections moves to uh retain section 80
subject to possible change later um all
those in favor yes okay unanimous good
yeah because there's nothing there's not
money there okay okay 82 all right now
this is just allowing them what other
people do so this one I wanted to maybe
um finesse okay so where is
this 82 82 the next page okay um by the
way did we tell division two to to
remove
81 are they are they aware of that so
section 81 is the same as House Bill
193 so um or similar too so I have a
feeling that house it's not needed in
house build too yeah I'm sure Mickey's
tracking that but I'll let him know he's
been following the Comm make sure he
knows about House Bill 193 so because it
may not come to finance because it's
it's not a money thing
so they may want to take that out okay
thank you all right section 82
so what this says is that this is
basically the thing that Ena Ables them
to not what they did in their budget and
I'm not thrilled with it and we may
probably make changes is that they they
didn't budget any overtime even though
uh almost all the correctional officers
are working serious overtime like like
they have five regular shifts a week and
three overtime shifts a week or
something like that
so so but instead they they
um budgeted many unfunded correctional
officer positions right and so what this
says is you can take the salary money
and the benefits money and all that
stuff and move it into overtime you can
shift shift money around what I'm
uncomfortable with about this is that it
allows movement
among different types of employees
employes right so so we we want to
budget a certain amount of money for
correctional officers right and some
other amount of money for secretaries or
cooks or you know whatever else and this
might allow movement of money from the
correctional officer salary position not
to overtime of other correctional
officers but over to the Cook and the
secretaries and and the other things and
so that what makes me uncomfortable
here um and so I was thinking
possibly making it
within
um similar jobs right
somehow within the same job you could do
this anyways representive camroll thank
you Mr chair I see what you're saying
but based on the fact that the majority
of the openings over there are for
correctional officers and that the
majority of the overtime being worked is
by the correctional officers as opposed
to Cooks and cleaners I I don't see a
lot of that happening so I I recognize
your point but I don't see that and um
this is the way they've been operating
for the last few years where it gives
the warden the maximum flexibility to
both be able to hire and fill positions
when the opportunity occurs and also to
be able to keep the place staffed with
overtime so I wouldn't mess with it okay
anybody else representative R um I agree
with representative Camas I also um I
have a question though but doesn't it
work the other way around too so if
there's uh funding and secretaries and
cooks and stuff they can and that's not
being used they can use that for
overtime yeah okay yeah um okay yeah we
we'll we're going to do things with this
Department I think but um when we get to
House Bill one so yeah so um okay I
mean you guys are probably right that
it's not the end of the world
representative muts I'm I'm I'm gonna
I'm going to pile on and um agree with
representative C and uh representative
rung I think in a in a in a period when
um you know Staffing is such an issue I
think providing the maximum amount of
operational flexibility is important
okay all right so uh representative
cell's moves and and representative M
seconds that we retain that we accept um
section 82 of House Bill 2 okay and uh
all those in
favor okay I'll be against okay so fine
we we accept that one okay
good all right all right
[Music]
um yeah now section
83 um I'm wondering if there's money
here in
that
um we're CH giving people is there any
raises or something in doing
this because it says compensation so
that's why I'm wondering about
that no I think this is just clean up
language and is already occurring as is
okay all right so somebody want on to
move to keep it all right represent rung
moves that we uh accept uh section 83
representative evil seconds all those in
favor keep that okay good
okay
um uh prison
Industries okay this is another cleanup
section with no cost um well not quite
CU what it's saying is and and if you
looked at the uh House Bill one I think
you would see this is that they're
moving
the um the cost of the employees in this
area to the funds received from prison
Industries right as opposed to from the
general fund so um CU it because it it
says it's taking out except for and
putting in all right right so those
permanent Personnel are now going to be
paid for out of this account okay I'm
okay with it assuming they are but um it
is a
change it is a money thing okay are we
happy with that yeah any think they're
trying to save money yeah right but
aren't Mr chair aren't like the
Personnel all that isn't that charge to
that account cuz I'm looking at line 34
it says charges for the sale of goods
and services produced by the industry's
program shall be sufficient to defay the
expenditures charged against this
account so it seems like everything
charged against that account would have
to be provided by the sale Revenue right
but look at look at line 31 so the key
thing is we're changing except for to
all
okay okay so right now it says except
for permanent Personnel all operating
expenses da da da is charged to this
account okay so now so now we're going
to charge all permanent Personnel
operating expenses all these other
things so we're adding permanent
Personnel to this account okay do you
see what I mean but but those expenses
have to be covered Anyway by the Sal the
expenses aren't changing right right
they're already part of this account and
so on it's the Personnel costs and so I
question them whether this account has
enough money to cover those Personnel
they said yes so yeah you know but yeah
it's a great store if you ever it's a
great I love going there I do too
yeah okay all right yeah so
so representative rang will move to
accept Section
84 um representative camell will second
it all those in
favor yes okay yes unanimous okay good
and and uh thank you so we're done with
corrections um how are we doing on time
we still got um
52 all right information technology
salaries is there money all right we're
now on page
52 this is just clean up
oh I'm wondering about that because in
section
we're moving some people into
hh's right from ggs or no it's only
adding in business relationship
management division so it's just
clarifying by division so that person is
already in HH that person's already in
HH yeah and the other one's already in
HH the other one's already GG and other
is HH yeah yeah um because I'm wondering
why is it that this particular division
um their director is an HH when somebody
else is is a is a GG do we know are is
this more important somehow or I do not
know off the St in my head but I can
find that out yeah maybe maybe there's
no real change we should just approve
this yeah Mr chair represent run um I
have a rookie question so is GG and
HH um salary grades yes okay for for um
unclassified I believe right yeah these
are for unclassified workers so so these
are the managers of these divisions and
HHS are paid a little more than ggs
basically
so okay all right all right so we we
happy with this yeah motion to accept
okay all right so representative cell's
moves and representative rung seconds uh
that we accept Section
113 all those in
favor okay
okay good unanimous
good all
right um now we have a bunch of
Department of Justice things and I'd
kind of like somebody to come and talk
to us about this because there's a whole
bunch of
these um I've reached out they did
respond so I think they'll probably be
able to be here tomorrow is the Hope
okay going to hold those till tomorrow
okay and I'm wondering by the way
Melissa on line 34 four this page 52 it
looks to me like there's a
typo um I kind of think that this a
civil rights unit should be section
D or you know should be a new
section right because this is a list of
things that the division of legal
council has and a civil rights unit is
one of those things on the list if you
see what I mean see what you're saying
yeah yes so go talk to the drafter that
unfortunately there already is a d and
an e right so so I think there needs to
be an F basically I see what you're
saying yeah okay all right but when when
we see them we'll maybe have an
amendment for that okay so now that
takes us
[Music]
through um maybe now back to section 124
on page
56 is it is that the next
thing so this is an exception to
91a um that
says uh you can keep confidential
records held by the executive branch
under seal in conf in a court file
or in a confidential court file so that
seems to make sense to
me
yeah any problems with
that
okay so 91a has whole bunch of
exceptions right of things you don't
have to
disclose and so under seal court stuff
sounds like things that shouldn't be
disclosed I have I have a real problem
with weakening anything in 91a okay I
would like to strengthen it and get more
of the exceptions out of there okay
rather than add them so you want to wait
and ask the Department of Justice about
this one yeah okay all right well we can
do that yes
[Music]
is defined in
91a um or the process for getting
something under
seal probably not right but I mean you
would you would think they would have to
add a definition if they if that was the
case but yeah I guess my my my thought
on that as well was who determines
whether it goes under
seal I would assume the judge but I
don't know
yeah all right we we we'll ask more
about that okay very good so let's next
is where are we I guess we're still in
attorney general stuff
right 12 section
125 yeah so this is oh now we're in um
judicial council is that what we
are
right um
do we know what the change is there
money in this
change are we because I I looked at this
section and and the $1,500 seemed to me
it was like $300
currently
um yeah I don't know a whole lot about
this section I can get some more
information on this one all right thank
you yeah so then so now we have a whole
bunch of judicial Council type sections
here um
and I don't remember them talking about
their yeah I looked in their
presentation it was in there and they
haven't returned a fiscal note worksheet
back to us yet so I can reach out for
125 to
127 very good I'll reach out
today
okay
um all right so we're going to we're
going to get more info from
judicial now
um yes representive Griffin I think this
is a I hate to
keep eating the same old drum but this
looks like it should be a separate build
of
me
okay well it's
repealing
12 it's raling
right repealing an
irsa and reenacting replacing replacing
BEP bill I think yeah I don't know why
it's tied
to it's tied to to money yeah excuse me
um representative Griffin are you on 128
no 125 he's still talking about these
sections right so we we'll get some
right and it looks like on 126 for
example we're add adding a bunch of
things that we can pay for right
so um and um 127 maybe we're paying
people a little more so yeah
so we'll get some answers to to these
sections okay all right wage wage claim
settlement account P 128 starts at the
bottom of page
57 okay what is this
special administer this
one okay
so
um
this this looks to me like it's it's
reasonable because um we already
have a law RSA
275 colon 53 part too um
which uh this is where somebody has a
has a claim against you know their
employer didn't pay them enough or
something like that and and and it's
getting adjudicated and so this is um to
make a a a dedicated fund for that
purpose right and and already they're
collecting money and distributing it but
but it seems like something that should
be separate from other government
accounts so it's a it's um creating this
wage claim settlement account are the
are these are these
situations where a government employee
is claiming they weren't paid or is it
private I think it's for everybody so
and and then I guess is it is it money
that you know pending the resolution of
the issue does the employer deposit the
money in here so so that if it gets
ruled yeah I think it's this is one of
those I believe this is labor department
right so it's
where you know somebody makes a claim
makes a complaint and the labor
department adjudicates it and then they
collect the money from the employer and
they pass it off to the employee and
maybe it takes some time you know so you
know I I tend to think this is okay um
yeah
but we can let me look it up just to um
and Mr chair I would it it should be
Revenue neutral because the fund would
disperse funds that would eventually be
collected from the employer right okay
right but that's correct this was a
request by uh the Department of Labor to
hold the funds they already do this
process but it was just to carve out
those funds and keep them into a
dedicated account yeah it it helps their
accounting I think yeah
so I'm okay with both 20 128 and
129 I'll second it all right um so
representative rung moves and
representative camell seconds that we
accept sections 128 and9 all those in
favor yes okay good unanimous very good
now 128 12 all right so these are okay
now we're on
um 130 to
um
so it's not the same RSA I don't really
know what yes so this is a different
fund and I I'm guessing it's no longer
in use right this
is uh special fund for Active cases
probably I can give you an update on
yeah go ahead okay so this account is no
longer in used the lap last recipient
who was pulling from this has account
from this account has passed away so
this fund is no longer
needed yeah yeah this was some
historical
thing okay I'll I'll move that we accept
13031 okay all right so it's moved by
representative rung and seconded by
representative Ms to accept sections 130
and 131 all those in
favor okay any oppos no Okay so here we
go 13 131 we got that
okay all right now hearings and awards
um oh interesting all right so this just
looks like a cleanup
thing um on the date right
so
um what's that I think it does expedite
payment because it says five days that
the payment will start five days after
the decision is made as opposed to the
decisions effective date I mean they
decisions effective date could have been
sometime in the future I suppose
but um yeah
I guess I don't really see real
difference issue yeah but but I I would
assume that they know what they're
asking for here seems very minor I I'll
move to accept it all right why don't we
let's oh yeah that's different than the
next one okay all right so
representative Ms moves to accept
Section
132 I'm second by representative rung do
we know representative Griffin yeah do
we know what the cost of this is going
to
be well it's it's not a a a state budget
type of item right this is workers comp
right and so the question is when does
the employer we selfemployed
aren't we self
funded for workers comp for workman's
comp I think we may be
self-funded
um yeah yes but there is no cost to this
this is just moving the payment I'm
pretty sure we s funded yeah if it
relates to us and not not people outside
of the
board outside of the
state I'd like to know a little bit more
about it before we vote on it
okay what information would you like
because every this is just changing the
payment to be we're still on a it I
think it's just clarifying this is just
right yeah cuz
cuz
um the
date yeah the date of the decision right
so it makes it clearer that that the
date the decision comes out is the key
date um and maybe there's some other
places in law where effective date or
some other date I don't know I think
they wanted the actual documentation the
issuance of the decision before the
payment was
made so it doesn't adjust how much
payments are made where the payments are
made from so I see what you're saying
we're just changing what exists yeah
yeah okay yeah I mean possibly it's
later than rather than earlier yeah I
think he answered my question okay good
all right so uh
so we're moving to we're still moving to
accept um uh section 132 right are we
ready to vote okay all those in favor
yes somebody move and somebody second
yes representative Ms and R Ms and rung
okay all right so all right so we
accepted section
132 sounds a little sh so representative
Sweeney we're now going through the
house bill two and we're about to talk
about Section 133
on page
58 okay uh representa McGuire do you
want to give a little what's that do you
want me to tell you what this one does
yes go ahead okay so this one um the
Department of Labor states that it's
just ex um it's clarifying the existing
existing composition of the compensation
appeal board that includes 27 members so
it's changing it to make up what the
actual board is right now because they
can't find the other other six members
is
that yeah okay okay nobody wants to be
on this board okay well only 27 price
money are quite PID are they paid yeah
all right so this seems reasonable right
yeah okay make a motion to accept
Section
1333 all right second it second it by
representative cell's moves
representative run seconds that we
accept Section 133 of House Bill 2 any
discussion all those in favor
okay unanimous good okay
132 all right 133 good now we're on page
three of our
list okay section
134 same oh it's it's
confidentiality all right so you want to
ask why do they want this is that
it so their response is this is their
extending the existing work workers
compensation claim confidentiality
protection to records and perceiving of
the compensation appeals board which are
currently not
covered so I
guess the compensation appeals board is
somehow separate from the Department of
Labor is that the
idea I don't know the answer to that I
can look because I I I would bet that
whoever um put in this RSA in the first
place kind of thought if they thought
about the compensation appeals board
that it was just you know one of the
sections of the Department of Labor
right
so but maybe not it seems like it's a
cleanup to me Mr chair that information
that the Department of Labor has they're
Bound by confidentiality rules but that
same information may be shared with the
workers compensation comp the
compensation appeals board so I'm I
would support accepting this
okay okay good yeah so we this will be
all right so any other points anybody
want to object to this no we're okay all
right so representative uh rang moves
that we accept Section uh 134
representative M second
anyone yeah all of them in favor I okay
unanimous all right we are going to
break for
lunch
and all right so we done we've done with
134 okay good so we coming back is it
1:15 Melissa yeah didn't say anything
okay and and Republicans we have a
caucus in this room it's actually
whenever you want because we're
scheduled the whole day so you can pick
the time of when we come back all right
let's make it 150
15 all
right
e
e e
two that'll be an item yeah okay all
right that's that's all I want to know
thank you
yeah yes so that raising fees seems to
be a a
popular uh method anyway okay so let's
go back where were we on our list
here page we're on page three Department
of Labor reports I guess but section 135
on page
59 is that
right and by the way we heard that the
Department of Justice is coming uh in
about an hour and 20 minutes
okay
so all right section 135 it's at the
bottom of page
59 oh it's just
changing
genders yeah this
is this this is an easy
one it has no it's just a
easy yeah yeah it's it's it's
substituting the words the Labor
Commissioner for the word
he
okay okay all right representative rang
moves representative cell seconds that
we accept Section
135 um all those in
favor okay any opposed okay good all
right
136 is that next Mr chairman I was going
to suggest that we change it to he she
they yeah right all that stuff too late
okay voted yeah
okay um okay workers comp hearings and
awards oh yeah so this is just about can
well there's two parts so no it's just
this it's just about um can you send
somebody an email notice and it's it's
um whenever somebody agrees why am I so
loud look at where you are 60 am I so
close to the microphone anyway
um so this is just a change on line 23
and 24 to say um you can send
individuals an email as opposed to as
long as they consent rather than send
these emails as long as everybody cons
sents
if you see what I mean so this this is a
nothing thing
okay okay represent rang moves we accept
Section
136 all right set representative Sweeny
seconds all those in
favor okay opposed okay no unanimous
okay that's that one now
137 ah this is the elevator fee so we
were thinking about raising this
one right
did we hear from him I have not do we
ask
um commissioner Maryfield about yes
represent R yeah I don't think this is
raising the fee what it's doing is it's
requiring the fee before the certificate
is issued yes right no problem with this
but it's just we had talked about
raising the elevator
fee at the time right and so but but we
were going to get a a confirmation from
the oh that's right I will follow up on
that request they did say that but I'll
check in with them okay find out yeah
and and you can check or Jack can check
when was this changed right
so um all right let's move on to
138 so we'll leave this open for the
moment um civil
penalties
um which seems pretty normal right all
right now the next one
um failure to
comply um oh things that could result in
a civil penalty is that what this list
is um inj adding to right they're adding
two things that could could result in a
civil penalty failure to comply with RSA
281a and violations pursuant to 27 6-
a so this is adding disputes related to
application for reimbursement from the
special fund for second
injuries oh this is second injury stuff
it is
yes yeah that's 140 we're talking about
section
yep RSA 281 a a colon
54 no no
no 139 which is L9 31 RSA
273 col 11a yeah but they're
adding
281a all right I'm I'm going to look
that one
281a is
uh injury fun
oh okay so this is the section that says
um first you give a warning to to an
employer and
then uh if if the defect is still at
30-day become still still gone still
there for 30 days then you can issue a
fine right so this is something we did
years ago to to give employers warning
that we're about to give them a fine
okay and so the list is things that
don't need a
warning okay so for example um failure
to pay an employee in full and on
time you you don't have to be warned
about that because you know you're
supposed to do that right things like
that so so this adds to the list things
you can find right away without giving a
warning
first
okay so and and they they look fairly
broad right they're they're
about um whole chapters right 276 - a is
a is a chapter and 281a is a
chapter they probably feel like they
have to act they probably feel like they
have to act quickly in that
case he didn't speak about this to did
yeah Mr chair I have a question yes it's
probably for Melissa or Jack um do we
know what the fund balance is of the
labor restricted
fund that was established in 273 colon 1
a b
1B what are you looking at uh I'm
looking at line 29 it says all monies
collected under this section shall be
deposited into the Department of Labor
restricted fund oh I see MH I was just
wondering what is the balance of that
have we been collecting a lot of
fines and what is it used for right is
it I'm assuming it's non-lps yeah
um it's unclear that could be their
their whole budget fund right oh that's
true like because they're they're an off
books kind of you know they're not in
the general fund they're on they're
they're in their own stuff so I have a
feeling that's probably their whole okay
their whole budget it's actually a small
fund it only has $68,000 in it the end
of 24 and what is it used for
it's funded from fees license
certifications and civil
penalties and then the
expenses so it receives about $400,000 a
year
with a little bit of a carryover the
expenses in 24 or 400,000 and that is to
fund the administrative Administration
Division and Inspection
Division so the fund is required to
finance the operations of the Department
of Labor not associated with workers
compensation so question represent thank
you so Melissa so you're saying it it it
just has a $68,000
$68,000 balance yes because it looks
like whatever the fees and fines and
penalties that are coming in those are
then expended to pay for um the
operations of the labor department not
association with workers comp okay so
whatever's coming in it's funding so
it's pretty close to being flat funed
with a little bit of a carry forward
every year I got it thank you you're
welcome all right but in any case
section 138 is strictly a um
technical type of Correction right I
mean if some other part of law says you
can do this this says okay right so it's
like
yeah all right second all right so we're
still okay just we'll just vote on 138
only okay so representative rung moves
and representative evil seconds that we
accept Section 138 of House Bill 2 all
those in
favor yes okay so that one is done but
that one's more of a
question
right so Mr yes re it seems to me that
if there are misgivings about it maybe
we could at least give the commissioner
of Labor an opportunity to say why why
if we're touching base on the fee issue
anyway yes ask about
139 she she says ask the commissioner of
Labor to comment on why section 139 is
there why do they not want to give a
warning in these particular
cases yep I can do that okay thank you
all right so we're GNA wait on that
one all right
wait okay now
140 second oh second injury fund
now we had this whole thing to get rid
of the second injury fund and we ended
up not doing it but I'm wondering if um
we might want to reconsider that um
because it's it seems like it's it's a
huge amount of work
for for not much benefit right it's um
did we have a well we had one last time
last two years ago chair yeah I yes
represented mon so for us newbies um so
is there there's a separate fund for
second injuries what it has to do with
is if somebody's getting workman's comp
for an injury and then they later get
hired by somebody else and then um they
have like a second injury okay um the
question is does the does the cost of
that apply strictly to the second
employer or maybe should some of it be
collected from the original employer
because maybe
you you know what I mean and and so um
it it tends to be a wash for any
employer of any size right like the
state for example right but but the main
problem with it was that people have to
apply for for taking money from this
fund right taking money from the second
injury fund everybody pays into it kind
of automatically but but when the circum
an happens then the the employer has to
apply to be reimbursed from this fund
and generally speaking the bigger
employers are better at that than the
little employers right and so it that
was the reason for getting rid of it but
but we ended up not doing it for
whatever reason so I'm I'm just trying
to understand
so so so workers come money that's
collected from workers for workers come
some of it gets deposited into a first
injury fund and some of it gets
deposited into a secondary injury fund I
think so I mean it's it's it's in
general I mean the first injury F the
main fund of workers comp is huge right
it's it's a lot of money um but the
second injury fund is there to cover
these circumstances and it may be it
could be one of these things where you
know if the if the amount in the second
injury fund isn't enough to cover its
expenses then it automatically draws
from the other fund or something like
that right so
so the rate of workman's comp the the
cost to employers of workman's comp is
based on experience right so when the
fund gets to be some limit like $400
million then the rates go down right and
then when the fund starts to drop then
the rates go back up you know it's one
of those kind of things so um
anyway um why don't
we yeah why don't we ask about that and
and because at various times I've talked
to the Department of Labor and the
department of administrative services do
you like the second industry fund do you
not like those and generally speaking it
seems like the Department of Labor
thinks it's um it's it's just extra
complication that's not needed right and
because they have to implement it right
right and but um Department of
administrative Services tends to say get
rid of it or keep it based on last year
did I did I get more than I
spent right and so um I don't know it
it's um I to me I would I would simplify
the world and and get rid of it but um
why don't we why don't we ask a question
of the Department of Labor to see if
they can send somebody to really explain
the the second injury fund okay um and
and see if you can re get back the the
bill that would would have gotten rid of
it and um present it as a possible House
Bill 2 Amendment okay and and find out
the history of it and all that okay good
so let's wait on this one
um so where was it uh okay so we are
on um
now oh is it the same
RSA 281a
54 281 a55 yeah so this is probably more
of the same right
okay
um now um so section 142
okay so 140 and 141 are together okay
142 this one is there because it's
paying for the um that's the that's the
line in house bill one that has 5
million the first year in 28 million the
second year yeah Melissa I'm only going
to pause you on that because you are
correct and that's what we heard but
then we did get follow-up information
from New Hampshire retirement system um
the business office versus what mark had
spoke about so do you want to
talk so okay so what what this is
actually requests from retirement system
it is in that same unit that the
retirement funds are in but it has
nothing to it has nothing to do with the
re I okay so they're just trying to
clarify that their funds are
non-aps um apparently there was some
miscommunication back and forth they
used to be considered non-aps and then
over the last year or two Das wasn't
sure if they were supposed to be lapsing
or not so they were lapsing it so it's
causing issues in retirements budget so
they're asking to put it in there that
they're non-aps funds
okay I
mean seems reasonable I guess I don't
know yes yeah um the main thing
is so I've I've gotten some feedback
just from constituent types that that um
we're we're letting the retirement
system grow too much right they they're
asking for like six or seven more
employees out of you know they have 78
or something right now and they think
the expenses of the system are too high
so
um you know this
uh there's a question as to whether we
want to allow that number of new
employees because it just basically goes
on everybody's um you know 80% of their
costs are property tax right so
um it it's uh something we might want to
not allow that to happen
Okay um but do we want to approve this
one thing yes are we happy with this
okay I move to approve section uh 142 of
hb2 okay repres do we have a second
representative Sweeney so representative
evil moves that we accept section 142 of
of the House Bill 2 representative
Sweeney seconds all those in
favor all right unanimous okay so 142 is
done but we we'll come back to the
budget of the retirement system okay
next is 153 oh no we did 155 on page
65 oh that's the one you
won yes
okay so I have I have now so this is
about RSA 31a suspending it I have now
read RSA 31a it's completely obsolete
it's full of stuff like in
1970 we're going to send so much to this
place and you know it it it is way out
of date so my recommendation here is
rather than put this in the budget year
after year after year why don't we just
repeal ours a 31a okay CU it's it's been
suspended for I don't know how long um
but it's it's not as far as I can tell
it's it's completely
unworkable um so my suggestion would be
replace this with something that just
says repeal RSA
31a represent MTH is there is there any
language in that RSA that um you know
enabling language
that for some kind of a program where
you know what you have to do is just
change the
date or is it just really really it's
similar it's similar in concept to what
we currently do with the rooms of meals
tax right sending money back to towns
based on a formula okay okay the problem
is it's full of it's one of these things
where it's like full of exceptions right
you know in this in 1989 do this and in
1970 do that and in 19 you know because
every year they decided you know for
whatever reason to give a little more to
this town and you know it's it's like
the the stuff that happened with
adequate Ed right and the spreadsheets
and all that stuff right they decided to
change the formula this year that year
and the other year and and like I said
it's it's been um it's been suspended
for for a very long time um Let me let
me show you where the source of fund is
because it's not the rooms of meal's tax
um it's other taxes can I go ahead so I
mean I I understand that we consistently
suspend it but it's kind of a big move
to repeal it I guess I'd feel more
comfortable agreeing to that if I saw
what your proposal was to replace it
okay well so the last time anything in
this
chapter was
changed is 1999
26 years
ago um I suppose uh Melissa could
research the last time it was a anything
was paid under this
chapter um but but you have an idea for
an alternative right only to no my
alternative is change the way we
distribute rooms of meals tax oh okay so
that one is elsewhere
right
um and and um I mean we could take that
from elsewhere make it a new RS what you
were thinking it is yeah I mean it it
it's reasonable um but anyways
so
um so so
um here's the the taxes that go into the
this thing there's the tax on Machinery
the tax on stock and trade the tax on
neat stock the tax on poultry the tax on
motor vehicle fuel pumps and tanks the
tax on certain Machinery the tax on
domestic rabbits the tax on fur bearing
animals the tax on portable Mills the
tax on stud horses and
jackasses the the the tax on Forest
Products okay so you know what I mean
it's it's it's obsolete okay well don't
you think it feels like a ways and means
kind of a thing though
yeah language I'm looking there is
language in 31
A4 that says under no circumstances
shall the amount appropriated under this
section be less than $47 million I know
that's why they always suspend it so
that's kind of that's a big deal right
right I mean if you can eliminate that
well it is and it isn't because because
the amount we send back under room's
meals tax is $140 million okay so you
know that's a big deal this is not quite
can we just think this is really big to
repeal this I think from a New Hampshire
municiple association thing I'd be I
mean i' why don't I would like to
suggest we talk about it after you
because you're thinking about all these
things I know you had an alternative in
rooms and meals and thought at one point
you had this concept of moving it over
here yeah because I thought I thought
that the way this had a formula it was a
similar formula to what I was thinking
about but it turns out so the formula is
in I don't know where it is
but
31a 4 but it's not quite the same it's
not really relevant I don't think I'd
want to go back to my constituents and
say that I repealed the revenue sharing
portion of the statute I don't know how
others feel but I don't think that would
get a good
reaction yes if we haven't used it since
1996 yeah yeah but it's it takes away
even the
option yeah you want to collect the tax
on forbearing rabbits I it's my favorite
thing well Dead or Alive to me it's
right for for uh uh a second look but to
just sit here and repeal it entirely as
a little Ang inducing all right
representative R um I I agree with
representative evil but when I'm reading
155 it just says suspension not repeal
yeah it is but what he's saying is just
to repeal it no no I I would accept 155
the suspension but not not to change not
to amend this to make it a
repeal all right how does other people
feel
okay anybody else
I would be okay with repealing it
okay no repeal
repeal
huh Mr selectman okay yeah Mr selectman
all right um now let me let me check
something here because um the I wanted
to look up whether some of these taxes
it refers to are themselves
repealed right because I think they are
rabbit said I never pay a tax
yeah so soct RSA I mean I had a lot of
all right so let me write down a couple
of these things right so it's um 73
colon
26 all right um 72 colon
17 72 colon
16 all right because You' think they'd
have to if they repeal that they'd have
to repeal all the references to that
right but it doesn't seem I feel like
we're doing this on the FL Mr yeah well
um we got a little time if we just
suspend it it's suspending the revenue
sharing there's nothing that doesn't say
in the future yes if we keep it we could
you know maybe Revenue share another tax
okay so for example it refers to RSA 72
colon 16 that was repealed on March 31st
1970 I mean you know
tax
yeah the the yeah
the could we just like pause the
decision for so we all would have an
opportunity to look at the statutes go
Ahad that I mean it's kind of a big deal
I think even though it hasn't been paid
all right all right we will wait we'll
come back that's fine all right now
where is what are we on here we're on
uh oh okay so that was
155 this is way
156 oh this one's
important so if we don't leave this
in it will cost us another 30 million I
think is the way it works because this
it was Alec it was put in the budget a
year ago to say in 20 f year 26 and 27
you will spend you will allocate this so
it's not like they set we set aside
money for this it's it's a program spend
right so so it's like it's a spend that
will occur on such and such a date so
this is a big deal
um okay can we can somebody want to make
a motion to accept section 156 I have a
question we had a a public hearing on a
bill to to fund
so how how does that work well I don't I
wouldn't want to repeal this if that
bill doesn't pass because I know in
marac we we have a significant
wastewater treatment plant we take we
take waste from over a dozen communities
and the state um to process and we rely
on these state aid grants to help fund
that if if this goes away the cost to
those other communities is going to
really jump
this is adding money to The Loan Fund
right so the Loan Fund is large and and
we add a little bit every time right but
but it keeps it can still make loans it
just won't necessarily make the last few
loans that that people ask for so
representative evil um I actually had a
very brief conversation with um bro sh
or somebody from the Municipal
Association there apparently is a
backlog even though the grants haven't
been made there is quite a substantial
backlog for these grants but it didn't
sound to me like it was this amount of
money so if we greatly reduced it and
maybe put 5 million in instead of 30
maybe this backlog could be worked off
or make a sub make some kind of effort
toward
it other thoughts
no he didn't like that thought yeah I
don't because to me this this if you
take this out or change it it's new
spending right and so in my big list of
new spending the thing at the top is the
YDC uh settlement fund okay not
this so um you
know this isn't this is an easy cut it's
not even really a cut because it's just
don't spend don't don't appropriate
right there's already existing funds
there is a fund and uh and they also get
money paid back so they into the fund so
yeah they I think they can go without
for two years okay all right can we vote
on this yeah representative months but I
I and I think this is what
representative evil was getting at I
mean I'm assuming that knowing that this
would be available
that there are projects in
development um that um will not be able
to go forward if we eliminate this
source of
funding so it would be good to know you
know what's what is the backlog of
projects yeah all right representative
Campbell no I don't agree the grants
haven't been made yet so nobody is
counting on this money the only people
that are counting on money are the ones
that have already uh put in their
applications where uh money was already
available this is this money never got
there so it shouldn't even be
considered okay so rep all right one
more um the reason I want to keep this
in is there are pending EPA regulations
on surface water discharge that will let
I I know they're going to require
upgrades to any Wastewater dis discharge
plant that goes into public
waterways and I'm thinking of the maram
river I'd hate to put municipalities in
the real bind that they have to comply
with those regulations and there's no
funding that they could tap to help out
with that
expense represent evil yes sorry I mean
I just want to say have it on the so
I'll be opposing this uh motion to
repeal it I understand 100% why you're
moving ahead with it but I'm recalling
the discussion that we had with Dees the
testimony on the bugo buck bill whatever
it was and I asked her very specifically
if the ability to upgrade wastewater
treatment plants uh related to housing
expansion and she said very directly so
there is a relationship from from that
standpoint because if these uh treatment
plants can't be repaired or upgraded
their ability to take on more customers
is affected so there's a there is
another alternative to do like a much
maybe five million instead of 30 but if
you know I just wanted to put that out
there okay anybody else like to speak on
this no all right representative leean
thank you Mr chairman as much as I'd
like to support the $15 million a year
for 26 and 27 we just don't have the
money we really don't we've got Buco
bucks that bills is sitting in our pain
pile so we could go back and pull on
that but I'm concerned that we keep
putting money there and giving false
hope to people that we're going to fund
these programs and we just don't have
the money yeah okay so let's say
representative Cambell's moves to accept
want make sure I got the motion correct
so would be um we want to repeal so that
we get we accept
Section yes make a motion to accept
section 156
okay so represent cell's moves that
accept Section 156 seconded by represent
Sweeny all those in favor please raise
your hands all right four against three
okay good five five to three sorry five
and three am I not counting okay
somebody somebody new showed
up oh very good okay
now
um now we're down to section
158 is that right I think we accepted
already 157 okay so
158 so this one I'm concerned about
because it it removes a fee I think
these few section this
section um and the 160 both seem to
remove
fees do you know how much money is
involved no
I don't know why Melissa no I don't on
this
one right maybe you can find out for 158
and 160 now
159 we were told that the decal program
doesn't pay for itself right so that's
that's this
one but Mr chair I know that um there is
a conversation going on between Dees and
New Hampshire lakes and we had asked
Dees specifically to get back to to us
on that so I would not want to repeal it
right now okay because there was but I I
don't think we really want to repeal it
D wanted to yeah they do want to repeal
it but New Hampshire Lakes is saying
that it's about to turn a corner and
make money and they were going to have a
conversation Adam agreed to speak with
them and I I know that that is happening
so it just seems like since we already
said but I don't remember them even
talking about 158 and 160 repeal I don't
really understand exactly what's going
on talked about 160 I don't have a recol
recollection of
158 yeah I just I don't know why they're
doing that okay so we'll get a we'll get
some I just more information I guess
okay 161 so we're going to wait slightly
on this okay oh once
Mr yes um
regarding
159 um that did make money last year and
I think to represent I mean I don't
think we should if it's making money
even if it's 4,000 I don't believe we
should repeal it and I I I did talk to
um Andrea Lomo about this from New
Hampshire lakes and she said the cost of
administrating it has gone down greatly
because they have the ability to accept
credit cards
and I guess not accepting credit cards
add a lot to the cost so even if it's uh
2024 it made
$4,200 um that's why would we you know
get rid of that if we don't have to it
seem like it didn't really do much
except sell people
decals right I mean yeah but in the
selling it raised money anyway I I just
feel In fairness do Adam said he was
going to talk to New Hampshire lakes and
come back to us so all right
um I don't I don't want to have a
program that costs them money either
Dees so we'll just um represent if New
Hampshire legs can prove that they're
making money I'm good with that and we
but again I'm just curious what you know
Dees was so adamant that they're not
making money so and again I know Andrea
very well from New Hampshire Lakes I'll
trust her opinion so hope hopefully
they'll come back to us pretty soon with
that with that answer all right 160
acquisition Maguire yes
16 the department did speak of this one
and they requested that to be
deleted out of the section they put it
they originally talked about putting it
in and then there was a change in the
federal funding so they were worried
about receiving that Federal funding
anymore and recommended that the
language be deleted oh deleted is that
in the um that's in the the long sheet
that they the red line thing um no I
think it's in the
so they just want it deleted from
hb2 okay well I'll make that motion okay
160 yeah that we we remove um 160 from
hb2 all
right all right so move by
representative evil second by
representative rung to remove section
160 all those in
favor okay good all right that one's
done all right so this one was crossed
down okay um now 161 there's a different
language on the red line form oh they're
adding the dam right they want to add
one more Dam to acquire for a dollar we
um already voted on that one the we did
with the red line yep we voted that
that's when it says amending pending OS
has that oh is that why you didn't make
it gray hope it's great on our sheet
it's great on yours maybe I printed it
it's great I printed it a day earlier
maybe I did too not gray on mine hey you
have an old
sheet it says
a no but I'm on 161 yeah
161 oh okay you're she oh you know what
you and I have older sheets you have the
310 2025 on I got the right one now uh
yeah yeah Min is 37 or something yeah I
have the same what you did okay it
should be one in front of you I've got
it yeah here it is
there's a new one yep you should have
one
represen to yours well that's right okay
there it is all right there we
go all
right good all right
so page four we're on okay
okay there we go all right so I see so
we accepted a whole bunch of these okay
167 okay so this is another one that has
Auto automatic fee
increases that I'd like to get rid
of so 167
right so the sections it's starting July
1st and so
on Mr chair yes I wonder if if it would
be more palatable to you because
I I I do not like the idea of having
bills come forth to do fee adjustments
because it it takes a lot of time and
energy on behalf of staff and
representatives and whatever to have
bills for fee increases so I'm wondering
if like on line 12 on page 68 if we take
out the word sh and put
May would you be more satisfied with
that no no because they
will I thought I'd throw it out there
okay I think we should be consistent we
already killed it in another area and I
would K I would vote I would move to
kill
this second okay so does goad I'm sorry
more discussion yes well no not I'm I
think I'm afraid that ship is sailed so
I'm not going to bark but the the the
thing where it says the commissioner
shall adopt rules does that relate to
the whole paragraph or just where are we
talking about it's the last bolded line
it's line 16 it says the commissioner
shall adopt rules to implement this
paragraph So if we're deleting maybe we
should just delete through the word
dollar
not sure because it says the whole
paragraph no no but the it has fee
increases which presumably we're okay
with yeah so I feel like the last
sentence of the bolded language on 16
and 17 we need to retain and the only
thing we're deleting is the section that
allows the increase CP I I sort of
wonder why that sentence is necessary
because in general Commissioners adopt
rules when we make Law changes right I
mean so do we really need to say so Here
There and
Everywhere yeah so I think it's I think
that is just they put in this
boilerplate for the Consumer Price thing
right because all of them are reading
that
way um just K starting well and the same
thing is true
for uh the next one on
page uh 168 section 168 exactly the same
well presumably they're going to watch
the live stream if they've got heartburn
over it I'm sure they'll let us know we
can change okay all right so so on
Section 167 representative campell's
moves that we accept this section but
eliminate uh the um bolded langage the
bolded language the two sentences uh
starting on line 11 of of page 68
starting July 1st and so on down through
this paragraph right line 17 yes through
line 17 yeah everybody clear what we're
voting on oh who seconded this I second
okay representative Griffin second all
right all those in favor yes okay we got
five and against opposed opposed opposed
no I'm I'll I'll you're in favor I'll go
six to two okay very good so
now this was
section
167 okay 167 so now we have same thing
in
right so do you want to make your same
motion make I'll make the same motion to
uh on Section 168 okay so all right so
moved uh by representative cell second
by representative Sweeney to accept
Section 168 uh after removing paragraph
Roman
2-a okay and I will just wage my
opposition to removing that paragraph I
I mean with some you know I suggested
language changes like adjusting and
changing but I just think it makes sense
to have
and I think it was fiscal committee was
going to be reviewing these too so it
wasn't as though we there it was out of
the legislative process but to have
separate bills to adjust fees for
inflation when we could have the fiscal
committee do it to me it's it's just a
waste of time and money um for us to go
through the bill process to make those
types of adjustments I just have to say
my piece Mr
chair I disagree with that because I
think think of the state's running a
surplus we should be trying to give the
money back to the people in the state
and one way to give it back is not
increase fees or lower fees
even
yeah represent yeah um representative
Griffin that's why I suggested that
language change it wouldn't necessarily
increase I was just saying that they'd
be adjusted so if if costs go down then
the fees would go down but every two
years it we we would look at that
Consumer Price Index and make should do
that bees would okay and that's just a
difference of opinion can all right one
at a time representative evil I know a
motion is already on the floor but
another alternative is that
representative rung could make a motion
for an amendment to the language
reflecting what you're saying and then
we could vote on that and if that goes
down then we could you know whatever it
was an idea representative
leean well thank you Mr chairman it's
someone that's been on fiscal for years
it's a big responsibility for just 10
people that try to track every
legislative intent that may come forward
I think putting the process before full
legislative review makes a lot more
sense and putting something like this
again before fisal because we have a
pretty full agenda every month okay all
right why don't we vote on this motion
okay um so again we're we're accepting
section uh 168 accept for paragraph 2-a
okay all those in
favor I'm going to be inconsistent okay
all right and opposed okay five to three
thank you okay next proga
yeah all right and we have the same
thing in 169 or very
similar
um yeah it's basically the same thing
and except that the appending paragraph
is still called paragraph
2- strangely enough okay
um so make a motion to to accept Section
169 with minus section 2A second
okay more discussion all right
representative I'm going to give I'm
going to give representative rung a
break in expressing her
opposition I'll express it I'll Express
mine um okay uh for all the reasons that
she's mentioned previously I think it um
it makes perfect sense to um have these
reviewed annually and um and then give
to the fiscal committee for their final
review right but I I would say
feel free to put in a bill to add these
sections back in next year right okay
because they wouldn't take a fact
anyways all right all those in favor of
this motion raise your hands all right
we got five against three okay five to
three all right that's
169 good all right 170 we're getting for
the
here all right
right what's that
170 we accepted
170 did we accept 171 no
no is that us no we did accept 1 yeah we
did one yeah I'm talking about
171 I have it says the word hold what
does that mean we're looking for an
amendment no we were I think we were
looking to see when the last time once
was this was amended but the other
discussion we had correct me if I'm
wrong
was that the standard for the fiscal
committee was $100,000 and this was
confirming conforming this for for GN C
which to me made sense I would that's
exactly right it's just CLE it was just
cleaning up it's just clean up pursu I'd
like to make a motion to accept
171 okay we have a second I'll second
not second all right motion made by
representative evil second by
representative cambrell to accept House
Bill 2 Section 1 171 all those in
favor okay any post all right unanimous
good now all right so this one's
okay so that one's okay and
172 oh I I said I would ask so I did so
um this is the one that on the face
looks like we're creating all kinds of
work for the Department of
administrative service Services because
they would have to
approve um all transfers of funds within
and among all accounting
units in every
department so um so I asked him about it
and he says well we're already doing
that anyway so it's
like they like this and they and they
have somebody who does this this is
their job right to uh to handle all
these these transfers and I think it's
just part of it's kind of a double check
to make sure that when they say I want
to move from here to there that person
is is in charge of making sure that
there is money here and you know and
there is space there and you know that
kind of thing so he was happy with it I
guess I'm okay with it motion to accept
section 172 okay I'll second it okay so
a motion by representative cell and
seconded by representative eil to accept
section 172 of House Bill 2 all those in
favor okay unanimous okay good so that
one's done next one Capital project
overview committee okay page 17 number
175 right um so represent representative
Wier and I are on the capital project
overview committee so um we met recently
and I raised this section with the
committee the thing is that the
committee is responsible for reviewing
capital projects and there's a quarterly
report prepared by Dees Das presently
and this would change the quarterly
report to an annual report and the
members of the cpoc opposed that change
so they want to leave it as quarterly
but the thing that has to be fixed in
this is that on line
nine there's still the word budget on
line 20 there's still the word budget
and on 27 there's still the word budget
and if you keep it as the capital budget
project then you undermine the purpose
for the change that we made in this in
the last bium and that is that all
capital projects should be reviewed
whether they come through the capital
budget or they come through the
operating budget so and I've talked to
Mr about it and I mean it shouldn't give
anybody any heartburn it's basically
corrective right right right so you want
to take just say the word Capital
project as opposed to capital budget
project gotcha and I had talked to
meliss about it okay so basically this
is a a replacement the only the only
change in this is that we're removing
the word project in the three place or
budget in the places I mentioned so
what's the advantage of doing this
quarterly in instead of
annually the well it's the same thing
like fiscal committee or anything like
this this is a this is a committee that
reviews capital projects and you know
it's a certain amount of responsibility
and work for das to prepare this list
but if you don't have the list then you
can't really um review it I did say to
the members there which it's a joint
committee maybe we could go to semi
annually and people just weren't for it
so I'm I mean oh speaking for myself so
in some sense we're making more we're
we're not this as as written would make
less work for the Department of
administrative Services yeah because
they'd only have to do it annually as
opposed to quarterly okay which is what
so it's basically leaving the status quo
I'm just cleaning up The Language by
removing the word project which we did
in different sections but we forgot to
do it here right so how do people feel
I'm I'm happy with the cross out of
budget but how do people feel about the
annual versus
quarterly aspect of it are we it's
probably not a big deal or what yeah I
think I think representative evil
explained it well okay that the board
probably needs it they want it let give
okay all right it's no it's no new work
I guess no no it's no new work I mean if
people wanted I mean I the thing is I I
would have a hard time voting against
what the people on that committee really
want the but as I say the there's a
halfway measure here you could do it se
you know semiannually but I I think
um and chair Wier is on that with me I
think they would be upset if we change
it oh was he there when you talked to
about oh yes he I was sitting right next
to him and I said remember this and hb2
Mr chair and we talked about it okay so
everybody wanted everybody liked it all
right so um so
representative evil moves uh Amendment
808h yes um to replace section 175 in
House Bill 2 yes she does and who
seconds that representative rung seconds
that okay any further discussion no
everybody in favor raise your hand all
right unanimous very good okay good so
this is amended
here just Mr chair I mean basically this
committee is like fiscal except for
Capital project I see that's kind of
what it's like gotcha okay very good now
now
um procurement and support services
section
um oh changing uh a little bit less
money in this fund here so the first
section a um is just changing from 6
months to 3 months and operationally uh
Das says that they think three is
sufficient so that was that change okay
and then in Part B was making it
non-linguist
[Music]
very good okay 176 is done
um after
ex
oh I have a note on that Mr chair yes go
ahead find out why it's needed did
anyone find out why it is needed
still pending still pending all right we
will wait then yeah it seems kind of
weird but yeah all right we will
wait by the retirement
system oh yeah we talked to the
retirement system about this didn't
we
yeah all right
um Okay so we're going to wait on this
one yes sir represent Griffin I'm
wondering how this changes what we do
currently is anybody aware
of what we do currently to pay fines and
penalties that's the question that we
have out to das New Hampshire retirement
wasn't familiar as to why this was in
their Das we asked those questions to
them so we're still waiting on an answer
we think it just got missed because they
said maybe it's it just come from the
general fund probably it's probably a
transfer but we'd like to confirm one
okay all right we'll find out all right
now we're down to
section
186 on page
73 all right
um okay so this one I didn't care for
with notify I think I think the fiscal
committee should weigh in on doing
this
right this is
allowing um the state comproller to
Simply take money from the rainy day
fund Mr chair speak with Mike Kane about
that and you do have an amendment
drafted if you want great yeah let's
take a look
I can give you a little background on
this if you would
prefer go ahead would that be
helpful so the amendment that you're
receiving right
now um represent McGuire can speak to it
if you want but I did want you to know
that that does match the language for
the approval going to fiscal committee
prior that does match what is currently
in RSA 9 colon 13 what this amendment
does versus what the current range day
funding does is there's a situation
that's going to probably occur this year
that doesn't fit into what is currently
in uh RSA 9 colon
13 so that is that when you have a de
deficit one of the requirements is
unrestricted General general fund
revenues in the most recently completed
fiscal bium were less than budgeted
forecast so you have to have a deficit
and it has to be revenues or less than
budgeted forecast for the whole bium in
order to transfer money out of the rainy
day fund this year the revenues over the
bium will not be less than what was
forecasted over the bium however there
will be a deficit due to spending so
this what was put into hb2
allows the comp troller to transfer
money to cover the deficit however it
doesn't put any restrictions on that it
just allows them to trans the funds
without going to fiscal the rest of 913
typically if they're transferring any
money from a deficit they have to get
approval from fiscal before they
transfer that so this amendment is
allowing just excuse me just for fiscal
year
25 with the deficit for the com
controller to transfer the funds non
withstanding the provisions of 9 col
13e with the approval of fiscal versus
in
hb2 it's indefinitely and it is the com
controller
only so what she's saying is the $160
million problem that we have in fiscal
year 2025 right now is not due to the
the finance committee's budget from two
years ago it is due to either the
legislator or the fiscal committees
extra spending over the last biennium
[Laughter]
and that's something that wasn't
anticipated in the current law because
the current law says you can only take
from the rainy day fund if your expected
revenue is less your actual revenue is
less than expected and that's not true
we our Revenue was fine and our budget
was
fine but we spent too much on top of
right so that was the problem okay um
anybody I I would like to move this
amendment um to section whatever it is
second 186 all right seconded by
representative Griffin uh representa Ms
I think it's it's worth noting if I'm
reading this correctly that one of the
things this amendment also does is it
says that the
um the controller just can't move the
money they have to request approval to
move the money right that's the main
point of this but that that but that
wasn't in the uh the the language
exactly that's right that's why the what
the existing language is is
objectionable right okay um because the
existing languages says control or move
the money all on your own right so you
know this is to get a little more
publicity for what's gone wrong you know
all right yes yeah I have a question Mr
chair so if our revenues were accurate
if the budget was accurate but we
overspent how did that is that because
the fiscal committee approved spending
with without the revenues well and or
the legislature just passed bills that
said spend this and allocate that and
there you go right okay all right thank
you you know that's why we tend to
discourage such bills in the second year
of the
B but sometimes we can't resist you know
it's like Ms to a flamee yeah exactly
you know so
represent that's true so you and I are
the responsible okay so so question
representative camp that being the case
where you just explained so they
overspent can they will she be able the
governor be able to take money out of
the rainy day fund to to cover the
deficit
since apparently she's violating the
rules or because we I see what you're
saying we met the revenue we had the
right budget so um this was not a case
where we didn't get the anticipated
revenue is she still allowed to take
money out of the raid and day fund to
make 2025 a whole so that's what this
does is not it's not the governor it's
the fiscal committee um can move money
from the r yes representative G um I
think most of the bills in the second
year usually say
the governor can draw out of any funds
available
so this by requesting the
fiscal uh
committee uh approve the transfer this
might
prevent it might prevent uh spending on
those bills that that otherwise might be
spent I'm sounding like a
a word salad yeah I understand
law okay
um
so yeah right so we're all set with the
motion everybody knows what we're doing
okay so all those in favor please raise
your hands okay unanimous very good all
right so Mr CH have a question before we
move on go ahead I'm just curious why um
there are changes in Section 8 5 but we
don't review that section 85 is there
any reason in particular why we don't
get involved with that uh that's a
division three bill with the division
three bill for DHHS yeah got it thank
you you're welcome
yeah 185 185 185 the thing they're
talking about there is probably Medicaid
related or something like that yeah okay
by the way
um there was a Medicaid bill from
um from um Municipal and County 20 22
million or 23 million or something that
passed on consent uh last last week
so uh that was a mistake you know was
with the wow that was a
mistake so anyways um somebody didn't
catch that all
right yeah it should have been on the
regular calar okay okay so now we
amended this right so let me write that
now
amended okay good we're done with that
Granite
Place uh the next one so I have some
information on this one as well if you'd
like me to speak to it so we we
discussed this one last week in hb2 in
2023 there was a provision to take the
funding f from the sale of the lonia um
the Laconia School in by Granite Place
one that funding and those parameters
only goes through this current bium so
this language essentially extends that
as it looks like the sale is going to be
late 26 to 27 if it happens so there's
two options with this you could keep it
as is which takes the sale um proceeds
which is about 10.5 million and it
purchas is this property or you can
delete the section and the sale of the
property would revert to the general
fund okay but we what about the payment
to the owner of granite
place the lease payments you mean
currently well this says we're going to
buy granite place right but currently
we're leasing it correct right so are we
obligated on whatever date to buy it or
we are not it's just an option if we
would like do you know what the lease is
per
year we can dig for that a little bit I
looked at quick quick glance but it is
already budgeted represent Griffin in
the current budget um the only thing
that bothers me about this
is uh the language in
it let me see if I can find it here it
says it'll be used for state government
office
space that almost
precludes leasing any of it if there was
excess
space and I think that should be
corrected Mr chair I'd like to give Das
an opportunity just to comment on this
because we don't know about the lease if
they
obviously and then but that's a good
point I mean because I remember in
discussions we talked about the possib
ility of leasing part of it if they
didn't use it all absolutely so maybe we
could just have Charlie yes we have a
response from him on this that's what
we're so yeah he said the state is a
purchase and sales agreement to sell the
lonia property I believe the governor's
draft of the budget calls for using the
potential expected proceeds he assumed
9975 million as General Revenue a year
ago the state bought one of the two
towers at Granite place where current
Justice Agriculture and the judicial
Council are housed we do not own the
other Tower and that's where the
administrative office of the courts
currently is I believe there's an option
to buy it which Melissa stated in the
lease I suspect the cost to purchase and
necessary mechanical improvements will
exceed his
9975 million he mentioned
earlier um and it's not a request nor
recommendation of Das he just that's his
General State yeah it's a request from
from the governor's office not D so so
the point is we could delete this pay
some lease payment and and gain Three N
million or something and at least
payments are already in the budget
because the judicial the the judicial
branch part of the courts are already
there so they're already paying the
lease to the Granite one but this is to
buy the other building right there's two
buildings right so we own one already
that's the doj agriculture Etc the
judicial branch is in the other one
currently and it's being leased right
now which the lease payments are already
in hb1 there was no adjustment for the
purchase of this building when all right
representative eil first and then well I
was just going to ask do we know whether
the whole building is being used now for
government
purposes didn't I didn't hear that in
that
response because I I just
I I think that's a good point you want
to give them the option to lose to
yeah all right why don't uh what can we
ask someone from Das to come by and talk
to us who knows all the details of this
and um what our possible options are
because if this is a source of 10
million bucks uh I think we want to
strongly consider
it representative mons as the the the
sale of the lonia site and completed so
it's under contract right now uh they
have to meet some stipulations before
they go any for further so I think
they're hoping to close within the next
months representative run
Mone yeah I was at that building I think
it's a North Tower we're talking about I
was there last week and they are doing a
lot of renovation I think in preparation
of some committees working out of there
but also if we delete this um it doesn't
preclude us from using the proceeds for
one Granite place in the future
does it that money would just go into
the general fund so this isn't like pre
preventing us from buying one Grant a
place when the sale goes through it just
doesn't put it into statute well we
won't have allocated any money for it
and
therefore yeah I don't know what happens
to the contract but but I do agree it's
$10
million that we'd have and also I do
agree and I think I raised this in the
in the when we previously talked about
this is I don't like it being restricted
that only for government because we may
want a cafeteria in there and we might
want to lease it to a vendor represent
yeah that was my whole point I mean we
as a
legislative office are going to move
down there and when we vacate it there
may not be other people available move
in we shouldn't
preclude the ability to uh to lease it
right so I won't take much change in we
here but but that assum as we buy it
right yeah and and something sounds sort
of weird is in the sense that it sounds
like we bought the one that we're not
using no we are using it we have doj
Department of Agriculture and judicial
Council are in the one that we bought oh
okay so the other portion there's a
there's like an Atri room that connects
the two or some sort walkway we don't
own that walkway over to the next
building we lease that from um
from a from a real estate person right
right and in that section we have the
office of the quartzer and it says part
of that building okay so currently we're
using a one plus buildings right okay
correct and we own one but we own one
and leas some of the other and and some
of further space in that going to be
used for the
legislature next year correct okay but
but after that maybe not right so well
we have a long-term Le we have a lease
so I believe there's no
um the courts is not planning on moving
out anytime soon there's just an option
at least a buy option I and they can
pursue that if they would like so if you
do here's the money set aside for it but
we have there's no agreement signed I
understand to buy it we would just
continue to lease it if we didn't buy it
gotcha um or put it in the capital L
good buy I remember we talked all
through this in facilities too I mean I
think the the big thing is whether as
you say we're going to say we're going
to buy it with the lonia state school
money or we're just going to figure it
out separately if you want to buy it and
who knows I mean the way things go with
the lonia state school it might not sell
anyway might not sell any all right
so let's get more specific numbers from
what what is
the what are the terms of the of the
purchase agreement end up the lease okay
can make an intelligent decision yeah
exactly sort of so you know once
again on my list of things to spend on
this would not bubble to the top right
right toil in trouble yes right okay all
right so um that's Granite place we're
doing a weit on
that um what's next
188 oh renewable ener all right so this
is a raid on the renewable energy fund
yes a raid an unconstitutional rate well
I don't know about
that um I don't think the Constitution
mentions the renewable
energy it's it more has to do with
dedicated funds I think that comment but
okay
um yeah or some of it or something yeah
yeah all right so oh well that was a
house maybe we
should wait for an amendment that raids
all the funds and put it here in section
188 and therefore we can wait on talk
about Toil and
Trouble Mr
chair all right um yes represent um
considering the vote the house took last
week
to raid well I don't want to use the
word raid deplete this fund um I would
much rather have the proceeds go to the
general fund than what was outlined in
that bill because some of it was going
to rate payers it would be enough to
maybe buy a cup of coffee a year I think
we could use that money better to yeah
you you can make that argument on
anything but all right I understand now
um did where was the we heard back from
um Edna about barbering and com
cosmetology right oh what was in that
memo which was in that
memo 18 188 we're waiting to we're g to
wait on that wait to hear what else
you're going to steal what other fund
you going to raid that's right okay it's
like the Viking
hordes orever you well as or I says
dancing through the field of dedicated
fund flowers barely
okay okay I like that idea all right so
has
anyone um peruse this barbering
cosmetology stuff no I'll admit
not
okay yes represent yeah I have a note
that oplc is going to provide better
language have we received that
no we have
not old sections now some of
this oh some of this is not ours right
190 is that's division to oh yeah we're
191 to 191 okay
very I can't find
light yeah I don't I probably have
a you shall receive
hi are you here to talk about Granite
place
yeah yeah please come
on so thank you for coming um
commissioner so do you know what the
terms are first of all how much we're
paying per year in leasing uh versus
what it would cost us to buy and we're
not paying one red Cent to lease
anything on that campus wow there are
two towers why would we want to change
that there are two towers on on the
campus okay
um I presume this is section 187 of
pable 2 yes which was not my idea and
it's not a request to the department
okay just for the record so if you pass
it or kill it you're neither doing me a
favor or hurting me okay um I have no
interest how about the
state
um so so there's two towers right
there's a slightly older one slightly
newer one they look kind of the same
with a with a thing in between a
vestibule if you will we bought one we
leased it for a bit and then bought it
we bought it from a local developer in
town whose name is Steve dupry who some
people have met um and it currently
houses doj and
Agriculture and judicial councel part of
it is going to be renovated that's not
being used for use
temporarily for the
legislature that Tower we own the state
owns um we bought
it a year ago is um we leased it for
about a year then bought it and that has
something to do with the terms under
which the previous owner had bought it
um so we own that either way some people
would like to buy the other Tower um
it's older it needs a lot of work we
have a we have an engineering study I
can show you which tells you how much
work it needs it currently houses on one
of its floors the administrative office
of the courts I don't know who else is
in it last I knew there was a pharmacy
maybe I don't know but um there's no
state agencies other than the courts in
that building we don't own it today what
fraction of the building is used by the
court a good good question if I were
guessing I'd guess they have a floor and
a half out of four but I don't know that
for sure um I've been to meetings there
but I didn't get a tour so
um um I think their lease goes up or
something anyway the developer has
wanted us to buy it and has pitched us
on it we don't currently have a use for
it um so we wouldn't buy it um we
wouldn't necessarily buy it but um
although if you pass this we would
obviously um although probably not for
that price
um that's sort of it
right so we don't currently have an
agreement with the developer that we're
going to pay x million ion dollar for
this building or something no okay right
representative mon thank you Mr
commissioner for coming in um so we're
not paying any rent for the the the
judicial branch they are they I'm sorry
yes we are they are they are paying rent
for their piece of the building I don't
I don't know how much okay um they're
that piece of it and that is a piece of
their budget that is not within my
department so I don't know the price and
then a followup I
mean um well I guess they could stay
there if we didn't buy it mean I'm
wondering where they would go if uh we
decided not to buy it so just for the
record we have no intention of buying it
right now um there's not we're not in
discussions about buying it we've not
negotiated buying it my understanding of
their lease which I don't have a copy of
which was negotiated between the
developer and um I think one of the
Supreme Court Justices um and it might
be the one who lives in my town um the
um
coincidentally
um uh I think it has a clause in it I
have been told though I have not read it
that has the rent go up at some point
and there are some people who think that
the state should buy it at that point
the legislature two years ago made us do
an engineering
study on I mean engineering we hired
smrt to do a study of the building like
a kind of like a home inspection if you
will to tell us everything that we
should fix and I I don't have in front
of me that study but I can get it for
you and it would something like 7 or $8
million of stuff that should be fixed
it's the older
Tower but um but no we other than the
the branch nobody nobody's in that
side uh representative evil I mean are
there from your uh knowledge are there
agencies who would be good to move over
there
um based on the status of the buildings
they are
in I don't know
that let me put it this way I in in part
of our planning process we're not
looking around going oh I I wish we had
a building we could dump people
into um so if we own the building we
would use it because that's sort of a
thing if we didn't own the building we
wouldn't need it and so so I don't want
to tell you this would make somebody's
life easier a lot of people would like
to go moving is really expensive and for
them for people to move you would have
to appropriate money for them to
move um if we bought the building you
would also need to appropriate money to
fix
it represent I mean so but the the
acquisition of the first building was
necessitated because we destroyed we
were putting up the parking garage right
yes so that's why we had to do something
with those people yeah OJ was in a
building and and they objected to us um
destroying the building they were in
while they were in it and not moving
them somewhere and and it was hard to
find the second choice was I think we
were going to we were looking at buying
half a Marshals and renovating it but
the judges I think were less or the
lawyers were less ecstatic about that
idea okay all right now why is
it so do we have a deal with them for
the space that the legislature will be
using to the space the legislature will
be using is in the building we own oh so
that building itself has a lot of empty
space it has the the the uh doj has I
want to say two floors and part it's
like three and four and part of one uh
so part of one is still open part of two
is still open and two also has
agriculture which is a much smaller
40ish agency and um judicial Council
which has for employees so it's a
smaller they don't take a up a lot of
office space and and the reason we don't
put the Judiciary in this all this space
it's not quite enough for them is
that you know I've not looked into this
I mean first of all because I wouldn't
dare suggest moving to Judiciary um I
think that wouldn't be good for my for
me politically um
the if we don't buy the building and
when the legislature's done with the
space that it uses I imagine the space
will be in nice shape for stuff and uh I
don't have a sense of square footage
though so I suppose I will look into
that okay and I'm sure they wouldn't
mind me looking into it either so right
all right um any other questions for
commissioner do we have some other Das
related things we want oh before we
leave the granite Place one thing I I
should say
this the sale of the lonia state school
property is
I want to be careful not to say it's
certain I feel very optimistic about it
it's a really good developer
um um with a lot of experience and I
think they like the property but they do
have the ability to walk away for for
almost they would lose some money but
not not not a ton um at any time so I
would say there's a really good chance
of that property closing in fiscal 2
seven okay and it's 9.9 million okay
representative
Griffin so this whole discussion started
based on my question of of why the
language in um in hb2 seems to preclude
the state's ability to lease space there
by saying it will be used for State
offices and that kind of implies that it
won't be used for anything else
and I could foresee situation like when
the
legislative uh function leaves there
there was vacant space and it might come
down to to needing to lease it and I
wondered why the language in here seem
to preclude that I I don't think um so I
haven't discussed it with with whoever
wrote the precise words and somebody in
the governor's office I think um but my
understanding is that let's say for the
sake of argument we didn't buy the
building and this passes I don't think
the language would make us buy the
building especially if we had to spend
more than $9
million um I think we could still lease
I think the language about State offices
is to Pro uh is to keep it from being
used for other random state uses it
would say that the state can't own the
building and then lease it out or the
state can't own the building and then
turn it into something else but my my
take on State offices is that's there's
some broadness to that so that um you
can't look at something and go well
that's not an office that's more of a
hearing room I think that would be okay
and but we probably couldn't turn it
into
um like a
DMV does the state lease any of our
property to private uh companies or
individuals we we do not um there are a
couple things that are almost exceptions
to that um we bought Hall Street the old
Bear right where where education is now
and on the site there's an existing Mar
County Savings Bank ATM it's a kiosk and
because it existed we have a sort of
unique language about that and some of
the court buildings are leased uh
typically to like the county attorney or
something similar to that but we don't
lease a private entities the state is
not only in lordon other questions or
meant to be we're happy uh was there
other Das sections that we want to talk
about uh section 177 you guys had
questions about state agencies using
funds in existing class 60 or other
appropriate budget classes to pay fines
and penalties from retirement system or
the IRS do you have that in front of you
commissioner I I don't have it in front
of me but I know the Genesis of it don't
don't ask me about about a word here or
a word there but um we so we
occasionally pay fines for things and
like uh recently independent contractor
violation of independent contractor laws
and agencies pay fines to the IRS for
that um and it's not clear where you pay
them out of right and for similar fines
that are paid on violations of the the
the ACA for example on Healthcare um
they're paid out of class 60 and risk
and benefits has language related to the
health plan that this mimics and and
it's it's to identify the finds have to
be paid and basically the state
controller said to me one day can we
dump something in House Bill 2 and I
said if we're doing something else maybe
um where we can just say this is the
line that should be paid out of so we
don't make random judgment calls on that
gotcha okay other questions any other
sections no no okay good I have a whole
bunch of email traffic with Jack though
that you might want to look at I suspect
he shares yes representative evil I
actually have a question but it's a it's
a section we already approved so there's
a section in here that for the capital
project overview committee the reporting
requirements go from quarterly to
annually um the the committee wanted to
leave it as quarterly and that's
basically what we just did but is it a
really onerous report to prepare on a
quarterly basis no and and I I think
that's fine we just we're we're you know
we're in the process of identifying
things that we can not do yeah because
we are going to have fewer people to not
do them with um and um that was one
thing we identified it it we didn't have
a sense of how widely read that is and a
lot of the a lot of it is compiling
reports from agencies right and some of
the data in that is great if the
agency's great in reporting the data
other people basically write yeah still
building and I've seen that and so we
thought you know maybe that but
quarterly is fine just I I had suggested
to the committee maybe we go
semiannually and they didn't go for it
so I tried thank you for trying I
appreciate that all right thank you very
much commissioner okay let's I can't
guarantee that someone will always be
[Laughter]
watching perfect yeah it's it's amazing
how many people watch this stuff but
anyway all right represent
say you need any more information
on M you ask them okay all right thank
you for coming uh General from
Amala
okay let's uh so we wanted to talk about
your sections of house built
2 and and figure out what's going on in
those so let's turn back
to where are we
here section 114 is that right
yes that's on page 52
okay
welcome all right welcome thank you
so did you want me to give a little
overview or yeah are these all sections
doing similar things or do we need to go
one by one or yeah they they really do
similar things and the best way to
describe this is it's really for the
most part cleanup and meant to codify
and just sort of clarify what's already
happening not really to to do anything
new um and one thing I would like to
just point out right off the bat is on
page 52 line 34 maybe this is just an
LBA thing to point out for OS
I think that's a small mistake leaving
office of the sister General there that
was meant to be crossed out oh I see and
the new language is the you know the
bold and italicized okay because we saw
this and we thought maybe the the
italicized part needs a d to be section
D but you're saying you don't want the
solicitor general right because the
solicitor general is actually not in the
division of legal council it's its own
thing how you know separate from the
other two divisions okay so good so we
can make the change different than in
that case thank you very much so there's
things in here like like last in the
last budget we we attempted to change
the name of the transportation
construction Bureau to Public Safety and
infrastructure in all places where it
was referenced and I think we just
missed a couple of places and there's
already a civil rights unit an election
law unit at least they were those were
established years ago which we have the
authority to do within the office
they just they're not codified or
mentioned anywhere in the rsas so we
thought it best to to Now list them in
the structure of the of the doj but we
beyond that there isn't a lot of
substantive change
um is the Civil Rights
unit similar in some ways to the Human
Rights Commission or not no the the
Civil so the Civil Rights unit enforces
the the civil rights act so the laws
against discrimination but specifically
the Civil Rights Act which says that
it's a it's a violation of the Civil
Rights Act if you either threaten or
cause physical harm to someone or damage
to their property based on animus
towards a protected class which is a
little different than discriminating
against someone because they're a member
of a protected class so if for instance
you assault somebody because they're a
member of a protected class that's of
course a crime
but it's also a Civil Rights Act
violation which is a civil violation so
we can actually we can bring a Civil
Rights Act violation even if you've also
been charged with assault or
sometimes you may not end up getting
charged with assault or you may not get
a hate crime enhancement in the criminal
context but we might bring a Civil
Rights Act violation it just just
depends yeah the one time I was almost
on a jury uh it was a case like this it
was um somebody was accused of beating
somebody up because they thought they
were I think gay if I remember right but
you know and there therefore you know
whatever so yes but then I was tossed
off the jury
so so I've never been on a jury so yeah
anyway okay
um anyways for whatever reason all right
let's go
on yeah the the one
other and I'm happy to answer any
questions but the one the one other
change that could arguably be considered
a substantive change I would say is on
page 54 line
17 where we are just adding to the
statute that deals with enforcement of
the election laws that we also are
enforcing violations of lobbying laws we
already do that but it's has NE it it's
not technically within the election law
units purview it just sort of falls
under the Attorney General's General
author to enforce the laws of the state
so we thought we would add lobbying laws
to that part of the rsas because it fits
most nicely I think within our election
enforcement
function um okay there was one
thing yes representative Sweeney thank
you thank you attorney general for being
here absolutely so in that same
paragraph starting at uh line 15 all the
way down to 25 it ends with line 25
investigation of alleged violations of
the election laws should we also add in
lobbying laws
there we could I think the reason that
sentence exists is because
we we submit that report I think every
um it's a biannual report so every six
months we submit a report to the
legislature of election law complaint
and the status of the complaints and how
they've been handled my guess is that's
why that sentence is there but I don't
think it would I don't think it would do
any harm I'm not sure it's necessary
though yeah thank you so why let's go
back up page um why is section 114 and
115 look like duplications of each other
it looks like the division of of legal
council is like listed in the law
twice that's a great question so there
um I can't tell you historically why
this is but the Department of Justice
that we have a what we sometimes think
of of all those doppelganger statutes we
have RSA 7 that lists out certain
functions and and um Provisions related
to the Office of the Attorney General
that's an RSA 7 RSA
21m is another section that also lists
off various functions and things related
to to the Office of the Attorney General
in some cases they are duplicative and
and I actually do think a useful project
at some point might be to just try to
merge those together we didn't take that
on in this particular hb2 and it may
actually be better for it just a
separate
bill on its own but it's a good question
and we have remarked on that before it's
actually one of the reasons why when we
went to change the name of the
transportation construction Bureau we
missed it in a couple places because we
have the two different sections that
deal with the office see all right but
but we will not do that at this time
okay right which is the problem all
right so um so that's basically it yes
representative Mon and this this may
just be a technicality but one of the
things that I noticed also in a number
of places is it
removes uh reference to duties assigned
to the attorney general regarding the
charitable trust see that p on page 53
lines 8 and n and then again on 24 25 is
there yep anything anything to
that no it just um the charitable trust
unit is within the division of legal
council but it's its own entity within
the division so we just thought that was
cleanup so rather than saying the
division is responsible for
administering the charitable trust um
the charitable trust statutes it's the
charitable trust unit that does that
it's within the division so it I don't
think that's a substantive change we
just we see it as as cleanup and just
kind of a technical
change okay other questions so this is
all the sections is or is there
more I think this is I think you want to
ask him about section 124 on page
124 I thought that was maybe judicial
Council but maybe
access to governmental records oh I I
don't have that in front of me could I
borrow your
section oh yes under
seal right
so um there's a list of exemptions to
91a right things you don't have to
disclose right Y and this one adds
records held by the executive branch
that are under seal or confidential in a
court file so
um is under seal defined somewhere
and so this is interesting I actually H
haven't seen this I I I can understand I
think what this is aimed at at least at
the Department of Justice if we're
litigating and there are there are uh
documents or other items that are part
of a court case that the court has
ordered sealed or if they're sealed
pleadings for instance grand jury
proceedings are typically sealed and we
file pleadings as as part of that but we
have
them I think what this is trying to say
is if a court has sealed something so if
something has been filed under seal in
court we don't have to turn over copies
of those
pleadings which we of course are not
allowed to do by by Court rule and court
rules have the force of law right so I
this might just be bootstrapping but I
think I would read under seal as a court
has sealed something or something has
been filed under seal in court okay I
can check at the office to see if we
suggested this language but but I
personally was not aware of this it
makes sense to me I'm also not convinced
it's
necessary because you wouldn't ever I
wouldn't we wouldn't ever do it anyway
right and I think if a core if if
somebody sued us trying to get us to
turn over documents that a court had
sealed the court is is probably going to
side with us when we don't turn them
over yeah but it it would cause expense
right yeah okay
yeah what's that I wonder if it made its
way in here because there was some
circumstance where somebody was
questioning and they felt like they
needed it yeah that's if if it what I'm
happy to do is go back to the office and
check to see if this came from us okay
it might have come you know from us and
then through somebody else right someone
might have checked with someone in the
office who said oh yeah that could make
sense I'm happy to clarify that for you
just to make sure that there isn't
something we're not thinking of
represent mths Mr chair we we had quite
a long discussion this morning about
boat houses and there was language in
here about a February 20th 25 oh yeah we
were G to ask you cut off do we want to
ask about that so if you turn section 15
coming SE section this is just page 12
we want legal advice yeah
all right is this the whole hb2 page 12
yeah so I also have some updated
information from Dees on that well when
don't we while he's here we'll see
so um if you look on line um 10 of page
12 okay it says any Boat House
constructed after February 20th uh Etc
shall not uh be such and such you know
whatever the question is can we put in a
bill that's if has an effective date of
July 1st something that says you can't
do something as of February
20th well if I if I might if I might add
represent and I think the other the
other kind of related question is was
there some because it apparently a lot
of this stuff around boat houses came
about as a result of litigation was
there something in some kind of a
settlement oh yeah that specifically
said February 20th I just want to just
make twoo clar ifications and I don't
mean to cut in but one it was over a
legal interpretation there was no
litigation on this just for
clarification into um de said this was
just a placeholder that they put in
there attorney for Mel can answer
anything else but I just wanted to put a
couple clarification so they want us to
change it is that what you're saying
what the date is a placeholder you mean
they just put in a placeholder ah yeah
so yeah I mean look off the top of my
head it would make more sense that the
date would be sometime
either sometime after the
statute yeah probably not even the exact
effective date right because someone has
to have notice they're not supposed to
do it in advance uh so that off the top
of my head that would make more sense to
me
happy yeah I think if it's a placeholder
that actually might be a question for
Dees because if it really was meant to
be a placeholder I'm not sure there's
anything I need to look at okay if they
really do want something that's before
July 1 then we should probably take a
look at that they said there was no um
significant no significant meeting
applied to that date it was just a
placeholder that put a DAT in there put
in there they but all right just
represent but I I just to track back to
the Attorney General's office I believe
the reason this is even in here was a
legal interpretation of some statutes
that need to be fixed so it they they
said it kind of came from you in the
first place not the
yeah the the substantive the substantive
language very well could have come from
us so I to the extent you have questions
about the substance I can look at that
it's not something I'm intimately
familiar with as I sit here
okay yes okay I think we can just fix
the date all good yes represent Sween
thank you and thank you for being here
again I don't want to abuse your time
but while we have you here last week we
heard a bill regarding the uh Office of
the right to know ab budsman and when we
look at the actual numbers of it it's
very expensive per case that he handles
so I while we have you here not to put
you on the spot do you think there might
be a better way for the state to answer
right to know
questions from cases that might come up
that's not as expensive per case when
you say answer right to no questions you
mean someone submits a right to no
request and there's some dispute over
whether do should be turned over right
that the current procedure is them to go
to the abman for an answer and if
there's might be a better scenario in
your mind that we might be able to
implement I guess ju just thinking about
it my my first question would not
necessar to you but that I'd be thinking
of is is is it expensive per case
because he's just not getting as many
yes cases as he should yeah it's it's a
$170,000 guy who gets 33 cases a year so
that's the in my mind the answer might
be just making sure people know he
exists and that's an option right it it
very well could be that you know the
general public just hasn't been well
enough informed that there
is this function right or that or
perhaps I'd have to take a look back at
his statute but maybe maybe there's
something in the statutory language
around the Ombudsman that for whatever
reason is narrowing the cases that that
can go to him but I it the
the basic idea of an ombudsman makes
sense to me and it strikes me that the
reason that it's so expensive per case
is he's just not getting a lot of cases
so I I think my first thought would be
how do we direct more cases that way and
get more cases flowing through him we're
not looking to create more work we're
looking to spend less money right right
so there are these other boards that
deal with cases where the the board
members are paid on a per per case basis
right one of the you know um labor
contract type cases and so on they have
they have Boards of people who only when
they sit they get $200 or $400 or
whatever so we're thinking in this
particular case of making the the
Ombudsman part-time and just when they
get a case okay there's a payment y
right so you know and I can certainly
understand that right we're not looking
to just create more work to justify the
money we spend yeah I just know that
there there are a lot of right to no
requests and I think one of the reasons
the Ombudsman was created in the first
place is that it's a lot more cumbersome
and takes a lot more time to go to court
so I would be
hesitant and again these just think off
top of my head hesitant to sort of throw
out the concept or think he doesn't have
enough work to do when I don't think the
number of right to know request is
dropped and I know that if somebody
tries to enforce their rights in court
it's going to take a long time yeah so I
I that that's my that's my reac he's
been operating for two years so you know
there is a fair amount of history there
yep assuming if we assume that it really
is just he's only getting 33 cases and
that's just about the number of cases
that's going to come through that office
I think making it a part-time person or
or doing something other than having a
full-time employee where you're paying
170k a year no matter what is probably
the way to go the one caution I would
have there is that you know it's easy to
say we're going to do that but you also
want somebody who's going to do a good
job and knows what they're doing and it
may be a little harder to do that it
just may be less attractive to find a
good person if it's a part-time position
or if you try to contract the work out
we have we've seen this in another
context with the hearing the hearing
officer function to hear appeals from
from decisions of councils at at Dees
so it right now we're handling that
because that function was transferred to
us but what we're doing is assigning it
to a lawyer one or more lawyers in our
office Who Are Walled off from the from
the council functions because it's
impossible to contract that work out at
the rate we' contract it out for we
can't find anyone to do it so it's sort
of the same I just throw that out there
as as things to think about yeah I mean
there's a there's quite a number of
these little I mean even the parole
board for for example right they they
meet pretty often but their pay is very
low because they're paid per DM kind of
thing right so yep um so I think it's
it's more for
retired uh attorneys who um you know
think of it as as Civic um service right
so yeah yeah we we have a great
tradition I think of volunteer boards
and commissions many of which do a very
good job and we don't
pay a lot of money for them yeah I think
ultimately that that is sort of a policy
decision for you all as to whether
something like the right to know
Ombudsman falls on that volunteer board
and commission side of the line or falls
on the side of the line where it really
needs to be a full-time employee with
full salary and benefits and all the
cost that comes along with that thank
you represent R thank you um thank you
uh Mr attorney general so with these the
dees councils and the right to know do
we have a lot of cases that end up at
Court despite the existence of those
councils and the
udman I mean how many appeals go to
court since we've had these councils and
udman in place I'm just wondering if you
know the the the reason we have them is
to discourage or or reduce the amount of
of appeals that go to the court level
are we successful in that I guess is my
question yeah with the councils my sense
is we are I mean that system's been in
place for a long time the only the only
recent change was that the hearing
officer function was transferred to to
our office because it makes sense that
you shouldn't have the councils and then
the hearing officer in the same
place um the right to no Ombudsman I
think it it sort of comes down to what
we were what we were talking about with
as far as the number of cases he's
getting is he not getting more cases
because people just are don't want to
use him or he it's not turns out not to
be a very useful function for anyone who
has a right to no dispute with a
government entity or is he not getting
more cases because people don't know
that he's there and that there's an
advantage to using him I don't know the
answer to that but that that would be a
question that I think is worth asking
and is kind of attached
to are we spending too much on it like
is it is it is it successful is it
really diverting cases from Court that
otherwise might not go okay thank you
represent M thank you Mr chairman and
thank you Mr attorney general like
representative Sweeney I want to be
respectful of your time but since you're
here
um is there an
opportunity to create um and I don't
know what you would call it but like a
um you know an appeals AB busman within
the Department of Justice where you have
one attorney or a couple attorneys maybe
that take on the responsibilities of the
right to know on budsman the housing
appeals board the Personnel appeals
board um you know to provide that kind
of um Avenue for people that have uh
that want to do an appeal but don't
necessarily want to go to court right
away where we where we kind of
consolidate that function within your
department the the challenge to say
consolidating those functions within our
department is that we also appear in
front of some of those boards and and we
do a lot of different things and we
split up functions and we have walls in
place to avoid conflicts of interest at
some point though we might sort of
overflow on how much of that we can
handle that said I think whether there
is a way to consolidate those functions
maybe not under the Department of
Justice umbrella but under say A you
know State appeals un you know Appeals
Unit or something like that a commission
on appeals you know name it whatever you
want you know consolidate some of those
functions in in one place there may be
some efficiencies to be gained there um
I would hesitate at least sitting here
today to say that putting that under the
doj is a good idea because if you put
too much of that under the doj you just
start to
create so many potential conflicts of
interests that we don't have enough
lawyers anymore to spread out the work
and put up the walls to avoid conflicts
representative evil thank you thank you
again sorry to take your time but this
is hey I'm here yeah right um so we're
dealing with um this Indigent count uh
Council for Indigent um folks crisis I
think I heard it I saw it call in the
bar news and of course we're going to be
working on the judicial Council budget I
just wanted to ask you a general
question what what you thought of that
situation how that affects the
Department of Justice if you have
any any thoughts that might be helpful
to us as we look at the
budget and if you don't it's okay yeah I
I do have thoughts yeah I think you're
referring to the Indigent defense crisis
right so just the the both the
difficulties that the public defender
has faced over the past few years both
with losing public defenders and then
finding contract counsel to represent
those who are indent and can't afford an
attorney in criminal
cases I think what I would say just
first as a general matter it's really
important issue right we need to make
sure that criminal defendants who can't
afford a lawyer have access to a lawyer
so have access to Justice that's how we
ensure that uh folks constitutional
rights are protected and all of their
rights are protected if they're charged
with a crime
I also think there's a number of factors
at play with the Indigent defense crisis
and we have been involved at the doj in
the past few years in discussions about
how to handle it because while we our
function is to prosecute crimes and we
oversee the County attorneys who
prosecute crimes a prosecutor's
obligations extend beyond just charging
someone with a crime and getting a
conviction a prosecutor's obligation is
to do justice an act the interest of
justice so we need to do what we can to
make sure that people also have access
to
representation uh that said I don't have
any perfect solution sitting here in
front of you today I just think it's a
it's something that every component of
the of the legal system and I would say
many different voices in the legal
Community need need to be involved in
the solution and there have been a lot
of people at the table in the past few
years but but it's a challenge the
challenge we were facing two or three
years ago was a backlog of criminal
cases because of Co I think we have
mostly come through that and we've
certainly seen a lot of uh a lot of
improvement in case loads and and uh a
lot of relief from the sort
of overload in in in workflow for
prosecutors we've seen the same thing on
the public defender side the defense
side but there's there's other factors
at play there that have continued to
give them some challenges so it it's uh
there's no easy answers but it's
certainly something we need to keep
working on and it is something at the
Department of Justice we care about
because again it extends to Our
obligation to yeah to not just prosecute
crimes and get convictions but but to do
justice so we're very keyed in on this
the attorney general or designes sits on
the judicial Council so the deputy
attorney general Jim buffetti who used
to be a public defender is sitting on
the IAL Council and and we're in pretty
constant communication about these
issues well just just just as a followup
it it is a true fact that um the we have
a responsibility to provide Council for
Indigent uh defense right so whether we
budget it here or and and if we don't
then they need more money we're
eventually going to have to pay it by
them going to fiscal so it's either a
pay now or pay later kind of a situation
and I guess the argument um that that
that they said that they gave when they
were here is if you can't employ
somebody in the public defender's office
it's far more expensive to hire
somebody outside the system yes so by
not funding I'm I'm not saying we have a
lot of money Mr chair but I'm just
making the point that we're kind of in a
box because if we don't fund it we're
going to pay a lot more later yeah I
think that's possible and I I would say
since I'm here and because you've given
me the opening I would say that the same
concept does apply in certain situations
to the Department of Justice right if
you know so if we don't have lawyers to
handle work inh house and we have to go
hire outside Council that can actually
end up being more expensive but I won't
say anything beyond that just thought
I'd put in my plug let let me ask about
that in particular so you get to make
decisions or your office does as to who
to charge with a crime and whether to
charge somebody with a crime right so
presumably some cases are more marginal
than others and is it your experience
that you look at your
resources and decide on these marginal
cases that maybe I don't quite have the
resources to prosecute this so I will
not and or or is it more
that everything that you want to
prosecute is obvious and and therefore
it's just a delay if you decide not to
prosecute now you know what I mean
because yep yeah it's a great question
Mr chairman it's a fair point on the
criminal side on the public protection
side we do have discretion and we do
make some of the we do make calls on
that based on available
resources what you'll find if you dig
into our litigation fund budget and I
know we've submitted some of that
information to you what drives up
outside Council spend if we don't have
internal resources is our civil defense
work where we don't have control over
the workload right because if the state
gets sued we have to defend the state so
we see that the same concept does it
play a
doj where we don't have resource
discretion when we're on defense and
that's the same with the public defender
right the public defender cannot control
how
many cases are charged that's up to the
prosecutors in the state the public
defender has to try to deal with the
workload that's there gotcha okay thank
you represent V well another thing that
I saw in this um in this article uh a
comment made by Mike I capino who I
guess is the chair of the board of the
Defenders was that um it really can
affect the workload the the um the
felony level so I guess right now and
for quite a while uh a,
of theft is a felony but if you moved it
to 2,000 or if you moved it to,
1500 it would or he said 2500 it could
greatly reduce the workload and that
might be true for you folks too I know
that's not the
only consideration but if you have
thoughts I this is what I'll say in in
on on that concept
I I think we need to be very careful
about making substantive changes to the
criminal laws because of money and and
workload right because that also affects
access to Justice if you're a victim of
theft and it's
$1,500 and now all of a sudden that's
not a class a felony anymore that's just
a misdemeanor because are worried about
workload you know that affects Justice
for the victim of the theft
and it also had you know affects it it
affects General deterrence right if we
just start watering down our criminal
laws because of workload that could have
some effects we don't want so while
there may be um places where we should
have that discussion there are other
considerations at play when you start
when you start going down that road okay
thank you yeah yeah just in general
we're we're raising fees for example
just in in some cases because they
haven't been Chang changed in a long
time and the you know $1,000 today is
like
$500 that's why it 20 years ago or
whatever and so this this case of the
distinction between misdemeanors and
felonies presumably that was changed you
know that was set many many years ago so
yep it's something to think about anyway
all right other questions all right
thank you very much for coming Mr chair
thank you members of the committee
okay all right
okay yeah so let's uh let's talk about
his sections here so back to page
whatever it
was um
okay all right page what page 52 let's
start with page 52 okay we have to
delete off of the
Sol right so so in section 114 we're
going to need an amendment to take away
office of solicitors General
yes okay all right so assuming that
would would the representative eil like
to move to accept sure um I move to
accept Section 114 with the amendment um
on line 34 of removing the words and
Office of the solicitor general
I'll second up all right so
um representative evil moves
representative cell seconds that we
accept Section
114 uh with this minor change on line 34
all those in
favor okay good and now we've got 115 16
and
117 oh do we ask about charitable trusts
or it's all the same it's all the same
all 119 119 115 through
119 okay we didn't find any other
changes like that no okay I make a
motion that we accept
sections 115 through
119 all right move by representative
cell second by representative Griffin to
accept sections 115 through 119 of House
Bill 2 representative wants to discuss
or he's voting he's okay all those in
favor please raise your hand okay
unanimous all right very good so now
we're done with
those um now what she was just were you
talking about The Boat House business on
page 12 on page 12 section 15 regarding
the date about boat house is being
constructed oh yeah and um Mr chair I I
would um like to support an amendment to
change the wherever February 20th
2025 occurs I'd actually like to change
that to September 1st because any plans
that are in process now it really gives
con usually contractors might need the
whole summer to schedule so either
September 1st or October
1st I don't see any new projects that
someone would agree to now um that would
even be able to be completed by July 1st
okay could I could I make a an
alternative suggestion to say something
along the lines of like 60 days after
the effective
date Mr chair I have some information
might help Melissa this so I've been
chatting back and forth with um Adam kpo
on this so right now they have been
holding off on issuing approvals for
overwater boat houses since the new
interpretation of the law so there isn't
anything pending
since then however there is one
structure that they approved that would
be affected but it it's been in place in
appeal since December of
2022 so I think they would like to get
this into law as quick as possible so
they can start approving stuff but
they're holding off on everything until
they have this codified in law so why
don't you rewrite it just so it's the
regular effective date of the of house
bill to okay good
and then we'll we'll get we'll see the
amendment then come back to this withraw
the
motion I I don't was we I don't think we
had a motion in a second did we we
didn't have a
second I didn't actually make a motion
but I'll move that we accept um section
15 with the amendment that any Boat
House constructed after the effective
date be okay yeah or
yeah and and then you want to
pass is it just 15 oh never mind okay
just 15 sorry just section 15 I'll
second or motion okay all right so
representative rang um moves that we
accept Section 15 but changing the uh
two dates to be the same effective date
as as house buillt to represent much so
I'm looking at my notes here and I have
a note said that we wanted to hold this
for the public hearing oh do we still
want to do that the boat house stuff yes
because it was 15 and 16 we wanted to I
think you said that I think it was I
think it was representative EV yeah
whatever that that the public is often
interested in in boat houses and things
related to boats I think she said it I'm
going to blame her no
I I don't remember but if there's only
if there hasn't been any permits
approved I think we have to you know
strike all the iron all right all right
all right all those in favor all those
in favor yes okay any opposed no we're
all okay good so we're done with that
[Music]
one
124 we just deleted okay what section
where are
we all right hold on a second let me
find the what page are we on oh the
under sealed
stuff okay so he's not doing it anyway
so we don't need it on this list I mean
I don't know the Attorney General seem
to indicate
necessary yeah I I think we should just
get rid of it all right so
representative Griffin moves and
representative rung seconds that we
remove section 124 of House Bill
2 further discussion no all those in
favor all right unanimous okay good okay
okay now should we go back to Granite
Place representative Maguire because you
voted on section 15 for the boat house
do you also want to vote on section 16
yeah that's what I was trying to figure
out it's just the penalty associated
with them not following the rule con
there you right um I'd like to approve
uh section 16 okay and who seconding all
right back to back to page 12 yeah they
were connected they were connected right
so we missed section 16 so uh um
representative evil moves represent a
rung seconds to accept Section 16 of
House Bill
2 any uh are we all in favor yes yes any
opposed no it's unanimous with
representative Sweeny absent okay okay
now so we got 16 okay now should we go
back to Granite place now that we have
whatever information we're ever going to
get on this is that that's near the
[Music]
end
okay it's section 187 on page
73 I have thoughts okay
represent um I'd be happy to delete this
section because I feel like it commits
us to do something um that may end up I
mean that needs more consideration and
we also gain the proceeds of the sale
into the into the general fund yeah okay
we all right with that yeah okay so
Granite Place section
yeah okay all right so representative
eil moves and representative rung
seconds to remove section
187 from House Bill 2 any further
discussion no all those in
favor yes looks unanimous
excellent
okay now back to what's next
barbering
barbarism representative Maguire yes uh
did you want to vote on 177 as well that
was um Charlie came in and talked about
that oh yeah so okay section 177 on page
72 I move that we accept Section
177 yeah yes I'll second it okay so
representative rung moves that we accept
Section 177 seconded by uh
representative
eel okay any further discussion I I
think it made sense that uh when you're
going to pay a fine you know where it
comes from
all right uh all those in
favor okay unanimous
great yes yes what yes remove we removed
removed yes yeah okay um what's left is
uh barbering on p on page
74 are we going to do anything about 188
now or wait that's the energy renewable
we decided to wait on that one okay now
I couldn't find the piece of paper from
Edna does somebody have it in front of
them yeah they printed it out for us
because it was from
Mr chair yes so they don't provide any
actual language they just state that the
executive director you know excuse
me excuse me gentlemen one one person at
a time please Jack so Edna doesn't
provide any actual language for the
barbering and cosmetology they just
state that they're going to get better
wording from the executive director
which we still haven't seen oh okay so
this one's on hold okay fine I found it
all right you found it and it says
probably what he just said
baring right multiple wording changes
okay oh yeah I wrote right there wait
wait for op see okay all right good all
right so have we asked oplc or are we
hoping that she
did I'm gonna follow up with that okay
thank all right representative rung I
don't know if it's relevant to the work
we're doing on hb2 but the Senate passed
SB
194 um I believe it went on their
consent that would lower the hours to
1,200 hours of
training um so I don't know I mean if
that bill goes through and gets signed
into law do we have to make any changes
to
hb2 I see because here it says 15500
hours
right yes we would um presumably the
Senate would know to do so um unless you
want to do it here but but um because
because in general House Bill two takes
is superior to other bills right so
typically what happens is like House
Bill 2's effective date is July 1st
12:01 a.m. or something like that so any
bill that happens that was an effective
date of July
1st is is inferior to House Bill too
right so um anyway so that's something
we have to think about or the Senate
would have to think about or whatever
right so
yeah and and the the place that where
the continuity happens is
because LBA helps the Senate after they
finished helping us and they remember
this kind of thing and and and figure it
out right
so
okay represent a month we just looking
through here
we haven't we didn't do anything with
the
Indigent defendants right the Indigent
no we are waiting to hear from the
judicial Council I believe right that's
correct I sent an email so I'm just
waiting I've invited them to come in
tomorrow as well as Department of
Labor okay represent I'm evil um Mr
chair I don't know what your thought is
on this but I think in off a lot of
people are very interested in what's
going on with the with the retirement
section so
we should like decide what day you're
going to do that so people know yeah
we're waiting to have get our Amendment
ready right I should have that tomorrow
okay but but
again I don't know that this new
spending is as high priority as
YDC so maybe we should talk about that
we can talk about that right now if you
want what would you say would would you
would you put the new spending for group
two retirement ahead of YDC or
not represent LE I don't think you can I
think you got to use YDC we know that
they'll probably be in for $75 million
we I don't know per
year prevent us from lowering that
amount even though we we are committed
to 75 there's nothing preventing this
legisl from lowering that as far as I'm
concern no you're absolutely right my
yeah it's it's based on what the
legislature allocates right so the way
the law is written I believe we have to
appropriate the money every bium or
every year or whatever so um we could
choose not to but the question is that's
my question is is if we have money which
would we which goes first anyway
represent
Ms I had a I had a meeting with the
State Treasurer on some other issues um
and we just happened to get into a
discussion um and if I understood what
she said correctly that in the past
there had been some at least
consideration or discussion I don't know
if it got to the point of discussion but
some consideration of
bonding the obligation for
YDC um and I from what I gather there
was some discussion that you know well
they that wasn't appropriate because you
shouldn't be bonding operating costs and
my immediate reaction to that when she
told me that was well I don't know that
that's a operating cost that's a past
liability of the state we had a
difference of opinion on that um I mean
is given given you know the revenue
challenges that we have isn't that
something we should kind of revisit or
at least
discuss yeah I I would be very reluctant
to do that because we've already
effectively bonded it by
what's in the law is the delay of 10
years over you know to pay it over 10
years with interest right so there's
interest built into the law that we're
we're paying the settlement fund so
effectively it already is right so
representative run thank you Mr chair so
my question is if if we don't fund the
YC fund at 75 million a year let's say
we cut it to 25 50 million does that
expose us to Greater costs by
encouraging people to go to uh Court
where we don't have no clue what the
award would be isn't that isn't that
settlement fund like Insurance to uh
indemnify risk that we might have if we
go to
court I'm not sure I I think the answer
is yes but I tend to think that the
court uh any kind of Court settlements
so the the settlements are not just
going to people that that
um go to the settlement process the the
settlements are also direct settlements
between uh the attorney general and the
plaintiffs right so those kind of cases
can be settled and that also comes out
of this fund so I don't know when
court cases are
lost uh if they are whether it comes out
of this Fund in particular or other ways
yeah that's a good question but a
followup is that we'd still be liable if
it goes to court we're still liable for
that amount sure and I look at the
settlement fund the opportunity for
plaintiffs to go there once they they
settle we know what they're settling for
and they're prohibited from seeking any
Court action like once they settle they
can't now go to court so I think I the
devil we know is better than the devil
we don't know um so that's why I think
the settlement fund should be our top
priority because it's protecting future
liability or fut it's indemnifying us
for future costs no it's not as I as I
stated earlier even um after July 1 when
PE no more people can sign up for the
fund they can the the remaining 23,000
or so that went through that system can
sue at any time the only ones that
cannot Sue are the ones that have
already been settled through the fund so
that so you know it doesn't matter we're
going to be sued From Here to
Eternity so uh I I wouldn't worry too
much about who's going to go to the to
the courts um we just I I think we do
need to settle with the ones that come
to the for the fund and um that's going
to end on July 1st and we should just
focus on that because we have no idea
what's going to happen in the courts nor
we have any idea
and to to your point Mr chair um so this
10 million that they just agreed to pay
out where's that coming from it's not
coming from the settlement fund
so yeah that's this is going to be crazy
I would just focus on the settlement
fund at least get those people out of
the way and uh I think that if we
appropriate something less than 20 than
75 million it at least gives them they
they have currently I think 28 to 30
million left in the fund uh to still to
Dole out if we give them another 25 that
will allow them to continue to make
payments um but I I see 75 as being
untenable at this I thought the letter
we received said that they're about to
run out yeah they they did and we've
only got yeah and we had the boy he
spent that quickly since he was here in
three
days anyways representative evil I
mean I I think we have a a commitment
under that settlement and it's also it
was it's it's something that was so
carefully crafted that whole statute
over a period of time and again if we if
we C if we reduce the amount of money in
that or anything I would I would I just
wouldn't do it without including the
attorney general in the discussion but I
guess this may be a stupid question but
why didn't the governor put it in her
budget is there some option out there
that she thinks is there for doing this
that we're not thinking of I don't I
don't understand why it's not in there
because that makes us the bad guys I
mean is that the okay I was trying to
see if there was some other rationale
other than that I I believe what we
heard was that she wanted to review the
whole situation right and so didn't want
to sort of make a decision about it so
quickly but but
I don't know for sure I mean you know
it's just it's really odd it it I would
agree with you okay any
other people want to people so I'm
hearing that that that from multiple
people that the YDC situation is more
dire than the group two situation right
if if it came to that so and and I feel
the same way so okay so so therefore
spending a lot of time on group two
matters may not make sense
yeahor I guess I just want to make I
just guess I want to just make sure that
people understand that um while I think
the YDC issue is an important one I that
in my mind that doesn't diminish the
importance of the retirement account so
I think they we need to be looking at
both of them okay yeah I mean I I'm I
think I'm with you but I also think
there's a lot of people that care a lot
uh this fellow in the backs roow there
was sitting all day long you know to
hear what might be said about retirement
I'm hearing from a lot of people a lot
of interest and I think we should at
least let them know the day that we're
talking about it here in the division so
they can have the opportunity to come if
they want okay that just seems fair well
and they can come to the public hearing
on Wednesday right so representative
camell I agree with representative Ms
the there's no reason why we can't look
at both that's why I'm saying we should
reduce the YDC but also take care of our
very needed emergency response people I
think we can do both but that's going to
mean that maybe the YDC has to have a
little bit of a sacrifice and again
those people were not providing public
service to us uh they they were in that
place for a reason not that they deserve
what happen but uh those were
circumstances the
bad circumstances that occur to them but
uh it's not in they're not in the same
league as people who are uh uh public
service and emergency responders I just
I I don't think it's fair to compare the
the two
groups all right it's all about money
okay and
so you know you can't spend more than
you have and and um and you have to
prioritize I mean that's that's all you
can do all right all right so we are
meeting tomorrow at 10: is that right
okay and and who's coming to meet with
us and at what time we are trying to
schedule Department of Labor which I'm
asking if they'll come in at 10:
tomorrow sending that email right now
they should be available tomorrow and
judicial um councel if he responds back
okay good all right good well we can
maybe even start to get into house bill
one things tomorrow if we if we have
time right okay good we going to talk
about this fee chart at some point too
or you want to hold off on that yeah no
I I think we
should okay I just I think you know I
won't be here Friday and Monday and I
hope I have an opportunity to
participate in the discussion all right
so um representative evil suggests that
we speak about um Dees fees tomorrow
because they brought a nice chart and
and gave us some uh some guidance on how
those fees can be changed but they
already had fees in here right
so yeah okay all right thank you so all
right we will meet at tomorrow at 10
okay all day it's yes yeah I mean maybe
not last too long because we have to go
vote and things like that right so yeah
okay anything else we're done okay bye
for